misheard
um
it would I mean they were it would
depend sometimes they were
super loving super
um happy and then the next night they
could be
arguing and
um initially when we first
when I first started working down at the
Lofts that things were cool
um
more than
more than moving forward
um things got a little more volatile
moving in the longer they were there
when did you start noticing more
arguments between Mr Depp and misheard
so
I want to say like the end of 2014 they
started staying down there pretty
regularly there were a few incidents
where
there were fights
um
but
March 2015 when when they came back from
Australia was when
I really started to notice notice a
change
and how often would you witness
arguments or fights during that time
from in in March
from March and thereafter
so when I came back from Australia that
the arguments were pretty regular
wouldn't say nightly but
every other night uh
several times a week
there there would be
arguments
and what did you observe in the
arguments that you personally witnessed
so it was typically I would come in
uh I'd be
I get a text from Mr Depp
I would go to Penthouse three which is
where they stayed
um
either stay by the door
as requested or
in the kitchen
um
and then I mean it was just verbal
verbal arguments
um
yelling uh it was typically Mr Depp
wanting to get out of there and
so there was the try
trying to convince Miss heard that to
let us leave and
um yeah I mean lots of name-calling lots
of
f-bombs you know
and who was the name calling directed at
so that was typically misheard uh
directing her
feelings toward Mr death and what do you
recall Miss heard saying in those
instances
oh dear
um
it would vary and to be honest I I tried
to not pay attention I was just there to
get Mr Depp out of there but
um
you know there were times I've heard
misheard call him uh
[ __ ] deadbeat dad
if I can say that I apologize to the
court if if
um a
[ __ ] washed up
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
um
you name it I she she's spewed it
how would you describe your own
interactions with Miss heard in the time
that you worked for Mr dub
all right what's the relevance of his
interactions
uh his interactions during when he was
involved in the when he was witnessing
these altercations boys don't ask that
question okay how would you describe
your interactions with misheard when you
were present during an altercation
between her and Mr Depp
for the most part
there was there were a few times where
um I was trying to get Mr Depp away from
the situation and misheard
didn't like my involvement in the
situation
um and she
on one occasion let me know how she felt
about about that and what did she say to
you in that instance
a lot it was a lengthy
um
one-sided conversation
um but she basically demeaned
my career choice
called me a [ __ ] yes man
um
and honestly there were parts of that
where she
you know she was like how would you how
would you feel if someone was involved
in your relationship
which I sympathize with
um
but
yeah she she definitely threw some
shade on me and and my
shows and career
now you mentioned that
um the arguments between Mr Depp and
misheard increased when they returned
from Australia in March 2015.
um when did you first see Miss heard
when she returned from Australia
so I picked Miss hurt up from the
airport
on March 9th
um
yeah that was that was the first time I
saw her when she got back and who else
was with her
gentleman named Ben King
who I later found out I didn't know who
he was initially but uh later found out
he was the
house manager or property estate manager
of the the place they were staying at in
Australia
how would you describe misheard's
demeanor when you picked her up at the
airport
you seemed normal nothing nothing out of
the ordinary
um
she was pleasant she was polite like
like she usually was
how much time did you spend with Miss
heard that day
um not a lot but at least the car ride
from LAX
to downtown L.A to The Lofts
couldn't tell you how long that took but
probably 45 minutes to an hour
um
I believe I escorted them or helped them
up to Penthouse three and was maybe in
there for
very very briefly a minute or two and
then
um
and then I left so overall let's let's
estimate an hour
and how close to you how close to
misheard were you that day
a car where I'm driving she
right behind me to my right so there's a
few feet there
I think when I picked him up
I don't remember if I hugged her or not
but I know I'd probably grab some
luggage so I was I was within a few feet
and what time of day was it when Miss
heard arrived at the airport
early afternoon
um I want to say they landed at around 1
00
pm
what if any injuries Did You observe on
misheard that day
I didn't notice any injuries
when did you first see Mr Depp when he
returned from Australia in March 2015.
I don't know to be honest
um
I know it was after misheard came
but I couldn't give you an exact date
and what if any injuries Did You observe
on Mr Depp when he returned from
Australia
so Mr Depp had his hand his right hand
um
heavily wrapped
I didn't actually see an injury but his
hand was um
was wrapped
now you mentioned that the arguments
between Mr Depp and misheard increased
after they returned from Australia what
arguments do you recall specifically
um
one in particular stands out
March 23rd
a couple weeks after they got back there
was a
an incident in Penthouse five that
I recall
and when did you start your shift that
day
11 P p.m was typically my start time
and where were you on your shift
so we at The Lofts there was a
kind of a makeshift command post CP or
uh guard shack or whatever it's called
um
that was in a storage room connected to
Penthouse five
via a patio so you'd leave Penthouse
five go to a patio and then
our
CP was connected to that patio
that's typically where we hang out
during during our shifts
and what time were you first contacted
by Mr depth that evening
again I can't say precisely but
um
between four and
probably around 4 a.m 4 30 Maybe
and what did you do after Mr Depp
contacted you
so when he he texted me and um
I was downstairs
I don't remember exactly what I was
doing either getting some air stretching
my legs
or grabbing some food
um but I remember getting the text I
wasn't in the CP when I got the text
um
he requested I meet him at Penthouse
five
and requested that I bring the nurse his
nurse that was working
um at that time with him
what was her name
Debbie Lloyd
and so
what did you did you go get Miss Lloyd
I did so miss miss Lloyd was staying at
a hotel close by probably about a half
block away
and being that I was already down there
I felt
uh four in the morning I wasn't gonna
and Mr Depp wouldn't have wanted me to
have her walk by herself
um
but I wasn't gonna go get the truck
either since I was down there already so
I walked over the hotel I I believe I
called the nurse just to make sure she
woke up
um and then I walked to the hotel and I
met her there
we walked over together to the Eastern
Columbia building
um
in the lobby we ran into Miss heard she
was at the front desk talking to
security or concierge I'm not sure who
um
Miss Lloyd stayed downstairs with Miss
heard I proceeded upstairs to meet Mr
Depp at Penthouse five as requested
um
was hoping to get him out of there
before misheard
came back up
um just because of plastic
sorry why was that
just because past experiences when they
would argue she would
try to prevent us from leaving
um
to the point I mean she's held the
elevator before she's physically tried
to keep Mr Depp from leaving by grabbing
his arm or standing in front of him
um I just wanted to get out of there to
avoid that
and what happened when you got upstairs
to the penthouse
so Mr Depp was sitting
in front of the the front door of
Penthouse five
um
I agree he had some bags I believe like
he was ready to go
um I greeted him
kind of got a feel for what was going on
tried to get him out of there
um
as we were getting ready to leave Miss
heard and Miss Lloyd
exited the elevator on the penthouse
level so they came back up
and um
Mr Depp and misheard
decided they wanted to continue
whatever conversation they were having
so
I let them into Penthouse five
um
myself Miss Lloyd Mr Depp and Miss heard
entered Penthouse five
I tried to stay out of their
conversations as long as they were
peaceful so
they were having a
relatively peaceful conversation so miss
Lloyd and I stood outside the door
of Penthouse five had the door propped
open
um to make sure we could hear what was
going on but kind of giving them their
space
uh initially
and you said initially what happened
after that
so the conversation
got a little louder got a little more
volatile so
Miss Lloyd and myself entered Penthouse
five
um
just to be around
um to
hopefully be able to
not necessarily mediate but just to be
there
um so yeah enter stood a little closer
to Mr Depp
and what did you observe when you went
back into the penthouse
so the argument continued
elements of kind of normal conversation
uh peaceful conversation but then there
were also moments of
yelling and anger from from both of them
um
and at some point I witnessed Miss heard
through a Red Bull can so
The Loft is three levels
um Mr Depp was down at the lower level
which is the kitchen area there's a
middle level which is was turned into an
office for misheard and then the upper
level was where the bedrooms were but
they were turned into
closets basically for misheard at that
time
um Miss heard and her sister at that
time
um
Whitney had had come in they were both
on the the middle level the office level
um
and I I saw Miss heard throw a Red Bull
can
from her position
um that struck Mr death in the back
anything else that you recall
at that point I moved closer to Mr death
I didn't care
um that I was
in the middle of their conversation at
that point I didn't want my client
getting hit with anything else so
I stood right by Mr Depp
um
the verbal
uh
Onslaught continued from from both of
them
um
Mr Depp was giving as good as he got at
that point he was he was angry and
agitated
um
at one point misheard through something
else uh either a purse or some sort of
bag or something that she had up there
um
I was able to knock it away so it didn't
hit him
at one point she spit at him
um
yeah and then just just a lot of
a lot of verbal
vitriol from both of them
what do you remember Miss heard saying
to Mr Depp on this occasion
and cheers
anything and everything
um specifically there was the you're
[ __ ] washed up
um
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh which which he called her as well
um
you're
again the the deadbeat dad [ __ ]
um
yeah I don't even remember what the
fight was about but it was um
it was pretty
the f word is my favorite word and it
was being thrown around
to the point where I was uncomfortable
so
and how did Mr Depp respond to
misheard's behavior
oh he was mad he was upset
um
especially after
she tried to spit on him
at one point
Miss heard and her sister
laughed
um Penthouse five
I imagine they went into Penthouse four
or possibly over to Penthouse three I
don't know if they were all adjoining
Mr death went upstairs and
rearranged her closet for her
um
threw down
probably every rack of clothing and
shoes
through one at least one down the stairs
um
yeah he he was upset
where was Miss heard when Mr Depp
rearranged her closet as you said
yeah say for sure but she was not in
Penthouse five she was either in four or
three
and you mentioned misheard's sister
Whitney do you recall when she arrived
in the evening
so Whitney wasn't there when we first
all walked into
Japan When Miss Lloyd and I stepped out
to give them some space she must have
she must have come in at some point
because she was in there when we got
when we walked back
did you see Miss heard again that
evening after Mr Depp was in her closet
I did yeah she must have heard what was
going on and not been too pleased so she
shortly after re-entered um Penthouse
five
as I was trying to get Mr Depp
out of there
and what happened at that point
so her and her sister both came back in
um
we were on the
middle level so her office level of of
Penthouse five at that point
um she was agitated
Mr Depp was agitated
uh
I felt it was time to get Mr Depp out of
the situation so I stepped
in between Miss heard and Mr Depp
um
telling Mr Depp that we were that we
were leaving and that it wasn't up to
him anymore
um
at that point
out of the corner of my eye I saw a fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
I heard and saw a
closed fist contact Mr Depp in the left
side of his face
and whose fist was that
that was Miss herds fifth Amber heard's
Fifth and where was where was Whitney
when this occurred
can't say for sure but I'm guessing or
my best guess is behind
um Amber
how did Mr Depp respond when he was
punched
the initial look on his face
uh kind of mirrored mine uh kind of a
look of shock like what just happened
where'd that come from
um
at that point
uh I wasn't gonna let Mr Depp get hit
anymore so I
moved him down the last flight of stairs
to the lower level
um
and told him we're leaving it like it
wasn't it wasn't up to him anymore
um just for his safety I didn't again I
had let him get hit by a Red Bull can I
let him get punched
my job is to ensure the safety and
well-being of my clients and
I I felt like I hadn't done that so
um
it was my time to do my job and get him
out of there
and so uh where did you go
so miss herden her sister
um
left Penthouse five
again I don't know where they went I'm
assuming they went through Penthouse
four
either in four or three
Mr Depp
was not pleased with me
naturally
um he went into the bathroom for a
couple minutes Miss Lloyd talked to him
um
and they came out and agreed that it was
time to leave
so as as we were leaving the front door
uh
Mr Depp
got right in my face he was wearing
sunglasses
and uh maybe not sunglasses he was
wearing glasses
um pulled him down pointed to the left
side of his face and told me that's your
fault
and I agreed
um and then we proceeded to the vehicle
and and we left the laws what did you
see on the left side of Mr Depp's face
uh it was there was already a nice
little
nice little Shiner
um
definitely swollen and red
uh it wasn't black and blue yet but it
was definitely swollen and red
at any point during this incident did Mr
Depp throw anything at misheard
no
at any point did Mr Depp throw anything
at anyone
no
at any time during this incident did Mr
Depp physically respond to miss heard
no
do you recall Miss heard's birthday
party in April of 2016.
I do
uh Mr mcgivern during the incident we
just discussed on March 23rd um
what did Mr Depp have on his right hand
so he had the same band
when he arrived from Australia so it was
heavily wrapped
um
yeah a heavily wrapped bandage I don't
know what was underneath but it was it
was definitely wrapped
do you recall whether it was a hard or a
soft cast
I do not
okay
now moving forward to miss heard's
birthday party in April 2016.
um
were you present at that dinner party
I was not
um
I started my shift
again around 11 P.M
the party was going on in Penthouse five
um
I don't
typically take part in get togethers so
I think I would probably hung out in the
CP shortly after I got there the party
kind of winded down
um
and I believe Mr Depp got there
he was late
um so I think he got there shortly after
I started my shift
um he went into Penthouse five again the
party wound down shortly thereafter and
then as far as I know Mr Depp and Miss
heard went back to Penthouse three
um shortly thereafter
did you see Mr Depp again that evening
that morning I did early that morning
yeah uh or the following morning
um
again I got a text
my best guess is around the same time
four there were so many
so many incidences
um I they're hard to keep straight but
um probably around four or five that
morning
requesting my presence in Penthouse
three
and how did what did you do after you
received that text message
entered went to Penthouse three
and what did you observe when you went
to Penthouse three
again a verbal argument
um
I think it was made clear that some
phones had been thrown off
thrown out the window or something
um
down to Broadway
uh
Mr Depp was again ready to leave to get
out of the situation he had his couple
bags over his shoulders
um
wanted to grab a few valuables that we
always used to grab when this happened
um
some framed letters from
uh either Hunter S Thompson or Marlon
Brando
um
yeah and then I I believe that we left
uh I think I got him out of the
situation again
we did look for the phone briefly I
think on our way on our way back to West
Hollywood
um but my main concern was getting him
away from the situation so I didn't find
the phone
um and then we we proceeded back to
back to his future properties
what do you recall about Miss heard's
demeanor that evening when you saw her
nothing that
I mean they were they were arguing like
usual in those circumstances but nothing
nothing pops out
what if any injuries Did You observe on
this heard that evening
I didn't notice any injuries
in your time working for Mr Depp have
you ever seen Mr Depp physically abuse
misheard
I have not
now you mentioned a couple occasions how
many times have you witnessed Miss heard
be physically abusive towards Mr Depp
obviously the March 23rd thing in
Penthouse 5
um
a physically abusive I don't know how to
define that but I have seen her
physically try to prevent him from
leaving before so
grabbing grabbing his arms standing in
front of him pushing him
um
yeah again I don't know if that's
physically abusive but that I've
definitely seen her touch him on
multiple occasions
have you ever observed Mr deputies any
drugs
I have
and what drugs have you seen Mr W's
are you talking non-prescription drugs
yes
marijuana
and uh cocaine
how many times have you seen Mr deputy's
marijuana
too many to count I mean daily
and how many times have you seen Mr
deput use cocaine
a couple
two
how would you describe Mr Duff's
demeanor when he's using marijuana
chill for lack of a better word
um mellow
yeah I don't know how to better describe
it just super mellow
and how would you describe Mr Depp's
demeanor when you've seen him use
cocaine
same
[Music]
so I've seen him use it like actual seen
him use it a few times I've
I've known of him using it other times
and
I feel like it it levels him out um
um yeah I haven't noticed any difference
when he when he's used it
have you observed Mr Depp consume
alcohol
and how many times
like marijuana too many to count pretty
regularly
and on how many of those occasions did
Mr Depp appear to be drunk
it would depend on what you mean by
drunk but not not many um
the only time I would say I've seen Mr
debb drunk was
when he would fall asleep on the couch
sitting up with his boots on
um
other than that Mr Depp
handles his liquor very well
how would you describe Mr Depp's
demeanor when you've seen him consume
alcohol
no no different than
any other time again super super chill
super mellow
have you ever witnessed misheard consume
alcohol
how many times would you estimate
again two minutes account
um she drank
fairly regularly
so I couldn't even give you a
guesstimate
on how many of those occasions Did You
observe misheard behaving drunk
I say I've other than the incident on
March 23rd where I didn't see her
drinking but I assumed based on her
behavior she was drunk other than that
I can't say I've ever seen her
obviously drunk in my eyes
I have no further questions
cross-examination
good morning Mr mcgivern
good morning sir so you've you said
you've worked for Mr Depp for about nine
years right
correct and he's he hasn't been in town
recently so you have another job is that
what you said
yes but you still consider yourself an
employee of his even today correct
I do and when you do work for Mr Depp he
pays your salary right
not on salary he pays my my wage yes
okay
he pays the money that you make for
working for him
correct and you've referred to him a few
times during your testimony this morning
as your client is that right
yes so when you're working security for
Mr Depp it's Mr Depp and Mr Depp alone
that is your client correct
that is not correct
well in the the altercation that you
testified about with misheard and Mr
Depp you referred to to only Mr Depp as
your client and it was your job to keep
your clients safe do you remember that
objection compound
I love that good
I do okay
so at least in that instance he was your
client not misheard correct
correct
now
the evening of March 23rd 2015.
you actually walked into the middle of
the argument with Debbie Lloyd correct
yes so
you testified earlier that you were
downstairs and misheard was downstairs
in the lobby and you'd gotten Miss Lloyd
but that's actually not accurate is it
to the best of my recollection that is
accurate in fact when you and Miss Lloyd
entered Penthouse five
Amber and Mr def were already in there
having a verbal argument correct
that is not correct
okay all right yes sir
Mr mcgivern do you see
um a document on the screen in front of
you entitled witness statement of Travis
mcgivern
uh
I do okay
and you
well let me ask you this is that your is
that your address below
the document's pretty small is there any
way for me to oh there we go
yes it is and that's that's where you
currently live
hang on one sec I'm sorry
that is a P.O box okay is that yours
it is okay
um
now this is a witness statement that you
prepared on behalf of Mr Depp uh in the
UK trial correct
yeah the the statement went away oh
there it is you see it yes it is
and
who drafted this statement
myself along with
attorney I don't remember exactly who
was it Adam Waldman
at that point I don't believe it was you
know
if you go to paragraph five please
on the second page
and you understood when you wrote this
statement that this was going to be
submitted to the court in the UK trial
that Mr Depp brought
and that this was your testimony on
behalf of Mr Depp correct
yes
and about two-thirds of the way through
paragraph five
there's a sentence that says when Ms
Lloyd and I entered his residence
misheard and Mr Depp were having a
verbal argument
is that correct
that I read that right
that is
yes so that doesn't say anything about
you meeting misheard in the lobby of the
Eastern Columbia building does it
no it does not
and when you entered the penthouse you
can't recall the specifics of what the
argument was about correct
no like what they were fighting about
absolutely no I don't and you don't know
anything about what caused the argument
in the first place correct
I do not but you do remember Mr Depp
being very angry
right
I remember both of them being very angry
yes and you say that he gave as good as
he got
when it came to what they were saying to
each other right
yes
you say they were both being verbally
abusive to one another
yes
and you testified that
at some point misheard misheard was on
the the mezzanine level right the the
level of her office or kind of the
middle level of the penthouse
that's correct and Mr Depp was on the
lower level correct When you entered the
penthouse
so when Miss Lloyd and I re-entered the
penthouse
that's where they were
and you weren't preventing Mr Depp from
leaving at any time correct
preventing him from leaving I was
encouraging him to right and he could
have when he was on that lower level of
the penthouse he could have left at that
point correct you wouldn't have
prevented that
no I would not
um but instead at some point he walked
up to the mezzanine and as you say he
rearranged Miss heard's closet
right
well that wasn't on the mezzanine level
that was on the top level but yeah he
rearranged the closet so he traveled up
two levels in the penthouse to throw
down every rack of clothing that she had
right
I don't know about every rack but he
clothes and shoes okay I believe you
said every rack so that's just why I was
asking you to confirm that you said he
threw a rack down the stairs correct
yes okay
and then at that point he went back
downstairs
to the mezzanine level yes now that
wasn't the only time you learned of Mr
Depp
um
causing damage in Penthouse 5 correct
couldn't say for sure nothing nothing's
coming to mind
he had uh you said he had something on
his hand from his injury that he
sustained in Australia right
yes his hand was wrapped now you weren't
in Australia uh with Mr Depp and
misheard correct
I was not okay
and
what he had on his hand could have been
a hard cast correct
sure I have I have no idea what was
under the wrap okay and isn't it true
that while he was on the mezzanine level
and misheard uh and and her sister were
there that he was reaching for Amber's
hair while he was trying to hit her with
that cast correct
that is not correct and you say that you
can't say for sure where Whitney was
standing on the mezzanine level during
this altercation correct
that is correct and it's it's possible
that she was standing in between Mr Depp
and misheard then correct
no well you say you can't say for sure
where she was standing so she could have
been standing in between Mr death and
misheard right
no because I stepped in between Miss
heard and Mr Depp
um so she definitely wasn't standing in
between them well in fact you saw Mr
Depp push or shove Whitney heard correct
absolutely not and it was only after Mr
Depp pushed Whitney that Amber stepped
forward and punched him in the face
isn't that right
that is not correct
now moving on to April 2016 you weren't
there for the party you said correct
Ira I started my shift while the party
was going on but you weren't in with the
party goers you said right
that's correct and you said at some
point Mr Depp and misheard went back to
Penthouse three
um but you have no idea what went on
between them in Penthouse three while
you weren't there correct
I do not
and
you said that you
gave Security Services to Mr Depp
primarily uh in Los Angeles is that
right
yes a little bit of travel but mostly in
in L.A okay where'd you travel to
um
Vegas
uh
up north we did a road trip kind of
they called it their honeymoon
um so Napa San Francisco
Big Sur
um San Jose
uh I've those are all with misheard I've
taken
Mr death to China before
um
okay yeah and then a bunch of bunch of
local stuff Palm Springs Santa Barbara
um stuff like that okay okay you weren't
on a plane flight from Boston to Los
Angeles with Mr Depp and Amber in May
2014 correct
I was not and you weren't at the
Hicksville trailer Palace in May or June
of 2013 correct
with them I was not you uh you were
never in the Bahamas with them including
in August 2014 correct
I was not you were not in the Bahamas
with them in December of 2015 correct
I was not you were not in Tokyo with
them in January of 2015 correct
I was not you were not in the Eastern
Columbia building with them on the
evening of December 15 2015 correct
I don't know
um to the best of your recollection
yeah if they were at The Lofts I
typically worked
every night but nothing
about December 15th is popping into my
head okay and you definitely were not in
the Eastern Columbia building with them
on the night of May 21st 2016 were you
I was not okay
um nothing further thank you Mr McGill
all right redirect no your honor all
right is this witness all right is this
witness subject to recall
uh yes your honored all right Mr mcgiven
you're subject to recall so uh just let
you know uh you're still subject to the
rule on Witnesses so you cannot talk to
anybody about your testimony or uh watch
any of the proceedings of this case okay
sir
understood man all right thank you have
a good day
your next witness
um Mr Depp calls Jack Wiggum who should
be waiting in the electronic Lobby okay
okay
all right Mr Wiggum can you hear me sir
could you do me a favor and just count
to one to five for me
sure one two three four five all right
thank you sir can you raise your right
hand
do you swear from tell the truth on a
penalty of law
okay thank you sir
good morning Mr Wiggum would you please
State your full name for the record
sure it's uh Jack Wiggum
where do you live Mr Wiggum
I live in Los Angeles
where if at all did you earn your
undergraduate degree
I earned a degree in finance from the
University of Florida
in what year if any did you graduate
from the University of Florida
1998
do you have any graduate degrees Mr
Wiggum
I do I have a
degree also
also in
2002.
Mr Wiggum what do you currently do for a
living
I'm currently a manager representative
for artists
would you please describe Mr wiggin for
the jury what a manager representative
does
so we you know represent writers
directors actors actresses uh mostly in
their pursuit of Artistic Endeavors so I
primarily focus on on film and
television but you know all Artistic
Endeavors
how does a manager representative get
paid
typically be a
what
industry data is kind of 10 of whatever
the deal is and Mr Wiggum what did you
do professionally after you earned your
JD at the University of Florida
I was an attorney at
firm quickly and manjis for
approximately three years
and
I segued from there to a talent agency
called CAA creative artist agency in
what year did you start work at CAA
I started there in April of 2004.
and Mr wigaman what capacity did you
start working at CIA
started at the bottom
checking mail and then uh
became an assistant for one of the
management partners
and then in 2007 I believe I was from I
became an agent and then right around
2014 I think uh I began co-running the
uh film and talent Department there and
when your job responsibility shifted to
becoming an agent at CIA would you
please describe briefly for the jury
what that entailed
sure we were you know also looking out
for Artistic Endeavors on behalf of the
clients the writers directors actors
actresses but we were also negotiating
deals uh and you know really pursuing
film television producing deals on
behalf of the clients Mr Wiggum did
there come a time when you left CAA
I did I I left in in August of 2020.
what if anything did you do
professionally after you left CAA in
August of 2020.
so I co-founded a management production
company called range Media Partners in
in August of 2020 and have been working
there ever since what type of company is
range Media Partners
it's a management representation
production company
do you know Johnny Depp
Mr Wiggum when did you first meet Mr
Tapp
I
I flee in on the set of black bass which
was probably I don't know 2014 or 15 and
then I met him very briefly at a one of
his music shows uh but more
substantively I sat with him uh I
believe in the uh the fall of 2016. did
there come a time Mr Wiggum when you
became Mr Depp's agent
yes when was that
right right around October I believe
fall of 2016. was that when you were
still with CAA
yes
when you first started with Mr dappus's
agent who if anyone assisted assisted
you
I had two partners that I worked on any
uh one was Brian Ward and the other was
Christian Carino
since starting to work with Mr depas's
agent in October 2016. have you had
opportunities to observe him interacting
with yourself and others
yes how would you describe for the jury
Mr Depp's demeanor on those occasions
objection relevant
the relevance is how he how he conducts
himself professionally which relates to
his reputation which is at issue all
right I'll overrule the objection go
ahead
you may answer the question
sure uh Johnny was always very nice
sweet in fact
um
you know artistic uh polite and
you know very thoughtful you know kind
of uniquely thoughtful about
how are you doing how's your family you
know he was he was just a thoughtful
person he always has been did he seem
Jen did he seem genuine objection
leading
oh sustain the objection to what extent
if any did he seem genuine
speculation speculation Foundation I
believe he can he can testifies to that
out loud go ahead
his her honor says her honor says you
may answer that question
kindness
and Mr wiggin prior to your first
becoming Mr Depp's agent in 2016 October
of 2016. who was his agent prior to that
I believe it was
um Tracy Jacobs at a company called UTA
and before you took over from Tracy
Jacobs as Mr Depp's agent what if any
research or due diligence did you do
with respect to him
again your honor it goes to reputation
which is this the core of the issue I'll
sustain the I'll sustain the objection
next question thank you Ronnie
were you aware of Mr Depp's professional
reputation at the time you became his
agent in October of 2016.
addiction leading in
a call for here
I'll overrule at this point go ahead
I believe I was
what was your understanding if any of Mr
Depp's professional reputation at the
time you began representing him as his
agent in the fall of 2016.
uh
Johnny's reputation in my opinion was
very he was very well regarded and
respected by peers uh in the artistic
Community
um
I'm going to object he first of all he
says in his opinion which he's not an
expert witness and second he's now going
into hearsay I'll rule the objection go
ahead
her Mr Wigan Marauders you may continue
well regarded
are you familiar Mr Wiggum with the
distinction between an independent film
and a studio film
what if any difference is there between
an independent film on one hand in a
studio film on the other
so in in layman's terms I'd say that you
know a studio film is a bigger budgeted
film it's it has a distributor a studio
in place so when you think of Disney
Marvel universal these kind of these are
big companies uh they're they're bigger
budgeted and bigger fees uh and then
independence like we call them Indies uh
typically are smaller budgeted more
artistically minded smaller fees and
often don't have distribution when
they're made
starting in October 2016 what types of
opportunities have you pursued on Mr
Depp's behalf
a wide variety you know uh primarily I
would say focused on on film television
and producing
what if any roles did Mr Depp have in
progress as of that time fall of 2016
going into calendar year 2017.
all right so
we we inherited
some deals it was uh there was two films
as I remember that we're going to go
back to back one
was city of Lies the Notorious B.I.G
film and the other was murder on the
Orient Express so those those were
filmed almost at the same time
uh and then and and they had
pre-existing deals uh that we serviced
and then he had Fantastic Beasts crimes
of Grindelwald
uh as well and then
we were we were in the process we ended
up finishing the sixth
film negotiation on Pirates of the
Caribbean
Mr Wiggum you mentioned city of lives
when was that film actually shot
to the best of my memory it was shot
right you know at the very end mostly
the beginning of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for
city of Lies
I believe it was eight million dollars
and you mentioned murder on the Orient
Express when was that shot
it was shot at almost the same time I
actually can't remember
which one went first they were both shot
predominantly call it January to April
of two thousand 17 I remember us having
to work out dates uh but they were it
was the beginning of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for
murder on the Orient Express
my memory serves me I think it was 10
million dollars
was murder a studio film or an
independent or what you call an indie
film
it was a studio film it was
Mr Wiggum you also mentioned Fantastic
Beasts 2 crimes of Grindelwald when was
that film shot
I believe that film was shot in the fall
of 2017.
what was Mr Depp's compensation for
crimes of Grindelwald
again that deal predated us I think it
was 13.5 million if I remember correctly
was crimes of Grindelwald a studio film
or an indie film
it was Studio it was uh Warner Brothers
and backing up a bit Mr Wiggum uh what
was the first business opportunity you
were able to secure for Mr Depp after he
came to you and CAA in the fall of 2016.
so I believe it was we
2017 was a really big it was busy he we
had a slot that summer and he wanted to
do a smaller film and it was uh the
professor I believe
how much compensation if any did he
receive for performing in that smaller
film The Professor
that deal was uh three and a half
million
was the professor an independent film or
was it a studio film
and Mr Wiggum how if it all was CAA
compensated for closing the deal on the
professor
so it would have been the normal uh 10
of the deal so the deal was three three
and a half million the commission would
be 350 000 to the agency
Mr Wiggum was 2017 a typical year for Mr
Depp in terms of the workload for an
actor of his caliber and track record
objection leading
yes
what other roles if any were you able to
secure for Mr Depp during your tenure at
CAA before you went to the new company
uh
a film called waiting for the barbarians
and a film called minamata
when was waiting for the Barbarian shot
it's waiting for the barbarians was
fall of 2018.
what if any plans did you and Mr Depp
have for 2018 calendar year 2018.
we had a very specific plan for that
year because 2017 was busy and he had he
had done Three Studio films
and and I remember him wanting to take
time off to rest and be with his kids
for first half the year and then
he wanted to go on a Music Tour which is
always
just made him really happy and that was
the summer
of 2018 and then
and then we had the slot for two for the
fall of 2018 and uh that's where we
spent a lot of time thinking about what
that movie was going to be and waiting
for the barbarians
was kind of a little gift because it was
based on a JM cutsy novel and Johnny's
you know very well read and knew the
literature the underlying book and Mark
rylance was in the film and it was just
like a dream actor that he always wanted
to work with
what was Mr Depp paid for waiting for
the barbarians
1 million dollars and I apologize if
you've already said this was waiting for
the barbarians and independent film or a
studio film
it was an indie independent
Mr Wiggum you also mentioned the film
minamata when was that film shot
that was the very
so I think January start was minimata an
indie film or a studio film
it was uh
how much was Mr Depp ultimately paid for
minamata
so is his fee his fee became it was
three million dollars
what if any role did Mr Depp play in
Pirates of the Caribbean 5.
was he paid an actor's fee for that film
uh
uh technically it was before my tenure
so but yes I would assume he was
Mr Wiggum would you please explain for
the jury what are residual or back-end
rights
I think the easiest way to explain a
back end is is it's an ownership stake
on behalf of the artist uh in the
success of the movie and
typically is only granted to stars of a
certain stature
and in addition to the fee Mr Depp the
upfront fee that Mr Depp was paid for a
Fantastic Beasts five which I know
preceded you uh what if any did
understand what if any understanding do
you have of whether Mr Depp had any back
end rights for pirates five
objection your honor Foundation
Foundation he said that deal was uh at
the other agency and he does he wasn't a
lot of he knows it that's fine go ahead
her honor says you may answer the
question
so you initially said Fantastic Beasts I
think you meant pirate five uh oh I I
apologize I I did mean for pirates five
uh what if any back end did Mr Depp have
for pirates five
uh I don't know what it was I know that
he had one
to it to what extent if any did Mr Depp
ever have a deal to perform in Pirate
six
so when we started representing him I
remember
I remember Brian Lord and myself
finishing a deal that had started at the
previous agency yeah we approach okay
hold on a minute
for the interruption Mr Wiggum uh her
honor says you may answer the question
which I believe is to what extent if any
did Mr Depp have ever have a deal to
perform in Pirates six
so we we finished the deal and then we
closed the deal with 22 and a half
million for that film is my memory
which studio which studio was involved
in the pirate series including pirate
six
so that was uh Disney
was Disney the studio involved in all of
the Pirates movies
yes
what role was Mr Depp to play in Pirate
six
I love it here's
I love it
Captain Jack Sparrow
was the 22.5 million to be paid to Mr
Depp by Disney or by some other entity
Disney
and when was that 22.5 million to be
paid to Mr Depp
it would be paid when he shoots it we
could like principal photography so when
the film shoots
who was the producer of the Pirates
franchise
Jerry Bruckheimer
does Mr Bruckheimer work for Disney
in 2017 to what extent if any was Mr
brookheimer supportive of Mr Depp
remaining in the Pirates franchise
I'll sustained injection thank you
Ronnie
putting aside his role in the Pirates
films did Mr dapp have any other
affiliations with Disney in 2017
yes
what were those affiliations
he
bring his
Captain Jack Sparrow
outfit and uh
wardrobe and and went into the ride
Disney and Disney had worked out a fun
little thing where he was going to take
the place of the automated you know
Captain Jack Sparrow on the on the
Pirates ride and so he would kind of
surprise people as they were going along
there and so I remember he did that and
then
in 2000 in May of 2017 we
uh he went to Disney Shanghai to help
open the Pirates of the Caribbean ride
there uh
what if anything did those affiliations
signify about the status of Mr Depp's
relationship with Disney as of that time
object
State the objection next question thank
you honor uh to what extent of any did
Mr Depp socialize with anyone at Disney
in 2017 to the extent you know
do you know whether Mr Depp socialized
with Disney during 2017 yes or no
Foundation
how do you know that Mr Depp socialized
with Disney and calendar year 2017.
because I was there
who um would you please describe for the
jury what you mean when you said you
were there when Mr Depp socialized with
Disney
we had a dinner and
spring of 2017 with myself uh Jerry
Bruckheimer Johnny and Sean Bailey who
was running
the film you know was running was
president of Disney
how did the dinner conclude
great I mean very very nice it was it
was a great dinner
as of early December 2018 so we're now
in December of 2018.
uh what if anything was your
understanding of the status of whether
Mr Depp would actually appear in Pirate
six objection
objection next question
Mr Wiggum did there come a time when you
saw an op-ed
that purportedly written by Amber Heard
That appeared in the Washington Post
Mr Wiggum I would like to show you
please uh what was entered previously
into evidence as plaintiff's exhibit one
uh Mr Gibson would you please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit one and your honor
uh may we please publish this to the
jury as it's been previously oh it is
thank you
um Mr Wiggum have you ever seen this
document before
what is it
I believe it's the
the uh opinionated op-ed in the
Washington Post that misheard wrote
Mr Wiggum when did you first see Miss
heard's op-ed in the Washington Post
it would have it would have been right
contemporaneous to when it came out
and Tom if you would please move ahead
to I believe the second page in
plaintiff's exhibit one
um
and drawing your attention specifically
to the third paragraph of the op-ed
misheard writes quote two years ago I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and I felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women for
women who speak out unquote
what if anything what if any
understanding do you have of that
reference
that it was regarding Johnny and
internationship
directing your attention uh Tom if we
could just move back up to the first
page of exhibit one
uh directing your attention to the title
of the article quote Amber Heard colon I
spoke up against sexual violence unquote
what if any understanding do you have of
that reference Jackson parents are
relevant what his understanding is I'll
load
that was uh
that was rather shocking I remember
because it was the first time I'd heard
an allegation of sexual abuse and
against whom was the allegation of
sexual abuse object
[Music]
s I'll sustain the objection next
question
Mr Wiggum directing your attention to
the fifth paragraph of plaintiff's
exhibit one
misheard writes quote I had the rare
vantage point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse unquote to what does that refer
Ence objection next question Mr Gibson
if you would please take down
plaintiff's exhibit one
Mr Wiggum how if at all was Miss heard's
op-ed different from other articles
about the couple's relationship
objection honored calls for hearsay
Foundation all right Mr Wiggum have you
seen other articles in the course of
your duties as Mr Depp's agent about
Amber Heard and Johnny Depp objection
yeah
thank you
um how with it all was the op-ed
different from other articles you had
read about the Johnny Depp Amber Heard
relationship
it you know it was a first person
account coming from the victim uh it's
extremely impactful
impactful in a good or bad way
it was it was
catastrophic because it was coming from
you know a first person account it was
not from a journalist if it was not from
someone observing it was from someone
saying this happened to me
Mr Wiggum between December 18 2018
the date of the op-ed in October 2020
did Mr Depp perform in any Studio films
sorry could you could you just repeat
the dates between December 18 2018 which
is the date that Miss heard's op-ed
appeared and October 2020
to what extent if any did Mr Depp
perform in any Studio films
zero no Studio films
how if at all did Miss heard's op-ed
impact Mr Depp's ability to land roles
in studio films between December 2018
and October 2020. objection your honor
calls for hearsay foundation and expert
I'll sustain that objection next
are you near the end Mr Chu I just want
to make sure okay I've got probably five
minutes okay that's good good uh what
effect if any did the op-ed have on the
release of minamata the indie film you
mentioned earlier calls for here's
Facebook hearsay speculations
sure yes Ron
what happened Mr Wiggum after the op-ed
but before October 2020
with respect to minimata
so the op-ed
came out in just
that was right as we were going on
Christmas break and uh minamata was
supposed to start in January and I I
remember
it was very very difficult to keep
minamata together the financing became
shaky the
the budget had to come down Johnny's fee
came down in order to save the movie
Tom if you would please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit 584 and we're not
asking to publish it because it does not
come in
this is an email chain with the subject
line quote uh Johnny Depp's Jack Sparrow
won't return check to him reading
from that
the
jury
that's on your honor weekend
um
Mr Wiggum do you recognize this email
chain
I yes now that I'm looking at it what is
the date of this email chain
uh I think it December 20th
December 20th of what year sir
all right uh December 20th of 2018.
Mr wagam Mr Wiggum directing your
attention to the middle email message on
plaintiff's exhibit 584. did you receive
this message from Christian Carino in or
about December 20th 2018 at 3 26 p.m I'm
going to object because it's a hearsay
document he's asking questions from the
hearsay document I love that question
we'll see where we go
her honor said you may answer that
question
yes I you got I see you know I see what
he's asking me
would you please explain to the jury
what the message was about objection
around
approach for a moment
Tom if you could please take that down
Mr Wiggum did there come a time after
Miss heard's publication of the op-ed on
December 18 2018
but before October 2020
that you learned more about Disney's
plans about whether it would cast Mr
Depp in Pirate six
all right I'm just asking whether he
okay I'll allow that
yes
when did that happen
in
2019
what happened
go ahead
this question
what what happened in 2019 with respect
to Disney you're learning about Disney's
plans uh whether to use Mr DAP in Pirate
six objection
yeah
what happened he said yes
I'll out what happened go ahead
it became clear they were going in a
different direction
when did you learn that Disney was going
in a different direction and no longer
planned to use Mr Depp and pirate six
well early 2019
who is Margot Robbie
she's a fantastic actress she's a client
a CAA what if anything did you learn
about the role Margot Robbie would be
playing in Pirate six
I think that culture here again
Oliver rule objection
I I learned that they were developing a
pirate's project for her to star in
after you learned
that Disney was going in a different
direction in early 2019 and no longer
planned to use Mr Depp
did you to what extent did you reach out
to Jerry Bruckheimer or Sean Bailey
it does not overruled out loud thank you
a lot
did you reach out to Mr Bruckheimer and
Mr Bailey jointly or separately
separately
what if anything was the result of your
Outreach to Mr buckheimer and Mr Bailey
also hearsay
I'm just asking what the result was
all right I'll sustain the objection
next question
after your Outreach to Mr Bailey and or
strike that
was your Outreach to Mr Bruckheimer and
Mr Bailey successful objective
objection I successfully made contact
with them but I was not successful in
rescuing
pirates for Johnny
when was the last time
you discussed Mr Depp's role in Pirate
six with Jerry Bruckheimer Sean Bailey
or anyone else at Disney
get an object your honor and hearsay
overall
2019 I believe
in addition to Pirate six did Mr Depp
lose other films between December 2018
and October 2020 because of Miss hurt's
op-ed objection I'll sustain the
objection
in it in addition to Pirate sex
did Mr Depp lose any other films between
December 2018 and October 20.
I don't think he testified that he lost
pirate six second of all she's now
contradicting the witness's testimony
which is inappropriate
good answer question
yes
after after the op-ed it was
impossible to get him a studio film
which is what we normally would have
been focused on in that time period
Mr Wiggum to what extent
did covid
or strike that to what extent if any did
kovat did kovid impact Mr Depp's
opportunities prior to October 2020.
I think it had an effect on on Johnny
like
uh like other actors to some degree but
we were still doing business especially
on behalf of you know
bigger stars that greenlit films and so
what was happening was we would we would
close deals or you know put together a
movie and then just set the start date
for whenever people could get together
and actually shoot the movie
Mr Wiggum in your many interactions with
Mr Depp have you ever seen him angry
objection your honor it's leading
a sustain us the leading in your many
interactions thank you roner in your
many interactions with Mr Depp to what
extent if any have you ever seen him
lose his temper
I never have actually to what extent if
any has Mr Depp ever raised his voice in
your presence
no he never has Mr Wiggum to what extent
have you ever seen Mr Depp engage in any
violence
never
Mr Wiggum other than misheard are you
aware of any other woman who has ever
accused Mr dapp of physical abuse
objection leave
thank you Iran uh thank you Mr Wiggum
all right I'll pass the witness all
right Mr Wiggum we'll do
cross-examination in about 15 minutes
I'm going to take a 15-minute morning
recess okay sir
all right ladies and gentlemen we'll go
ahead and take our morning recess do not
discuss the case with anybody and don't
do any outside research okay
Mr Wiggum what I'll do is put you in the
lobby and then I'll you won't see
anything in about 15 minutes I'll bring
it back okay
all right thank you
all right at this point we'll just come
back at noon okay all right all right
thank you
ready for the jury okay
okay
excuse me
all right all right Mr wigman can you
hear me okay
yes ma'am
all right
as soon as you ask Miss first question
he should pop up there he'll come up
there yeah cross-examination thank you
your honor
Mr Wiggum you testified that you closed
a deal
for Mr debb for pirate six with him
acting as Jack Sparrow do you recall
that testimony
Mr William could you do me a favor and
just count from one to five for me so I
can get you on my big screens here
sure one two three four five
I'm not getting on this there we go okay
thank you sir I appreciate I'm sorry
but in fact Mr Wiggum it's not true that
Mr Depp ever had a contract with Disney
for pirate six isn't that correct
can you explain that question or that
position have you ever seen a contract
that provides for Mr Depp to play pirate
six
I to the best of my knowledge my memory
myself and my partner posed an optional
picture deal for the amount of money of
what that
picture would be for Johnny
and you would you would make sure to
have that in writing wouldn't you
you know that would normally go through
legal counsel in terms of
the codification of it do you have any
explanation for why there exists nothing
no piece of paper nothing suggesting
that Mr Depp ever
had to deal with Disney for pirate six a
Texan lack of foundation compound I'll
love it
so
close when I was an agent we would work
on many deals where I actually wouldn't
see contracts they were verbal in nature
and then you know especially on on
optional pictures just so there was an
understanding of what the money would be
so do you have an explanation why there
is not even a piece of paper not an
email not a text not a piece not a
document nothing that suggests that Mr
Depp is going to be in Pirate six as
Jack Sparrow objection Aston answered I
don't believe it was so overruled a lot
uh it I mean if you're asking me in my
opinion it wouldn't necessarily be
alarming because that would be a
conversation usually to understand
Disney's going to want to know are we on
the same
uh are we on the same uh page about what
the money's going to be and most of that
conversation if I remember correctly was
also
with one of Johnny's lawyer
okay and and so you you have so Johnny's
lawyer was discussing this but there's
no document
do you have an explanation for that you
well you may know better than me if
there is a document but that that was
Jake Bloom you know at the time I
believe if memory serves me correct all
right but you would it be fair to say
that you have never seen a document that
provides that Mr Depp was going to be in
Pirate six
it would be fair to say that it was
consistent with a lot of the
conversations that I would have on
behalf of big stars where it was verbal
and there was an understanding of what
the what the deal was going to be Mr
Wiggum if you please answer my question
harassment he did answer the question
hello you want to ask your question
thank you
sure
Judy
can you repeat the question sorry Judy
can you read that back thank you
Jeff was going to be Empire six
it it would be fair to say that I have
not seen a document on Pirates now just
so you know I don't Mr Wiggum Mr Wiggum
I don't I don't need you to give me
extra I just want you to answer mine I
just want to know have you ever seen a
document that says Mr Depp is going to
be in Pirate six
I I only to fully answer the question
though I think there's there's some
cards that's an easy yes or no have you
seen a document
technically I
perhaps have because it connects to all
the other Pirates films it's just a
modification of a new document so I I
have not seen 22.5 million written on a
page you're correct about that okay now
you in fact uh had discussions back in
2016 and 2017 with Mr Bailey Sean Bailey
you talked about him a little bit ago
right
and and and you also had discussions
with Jerry Bruckheimer in 2016 and 2017
correct
yes about Mr debb potentially being in
Pirate six correct
and then you and then you had
discussions in 2018 with Mr Bailey and
he was quite non-committal about whether
Mr Depp would be in Pirate six correct
objection hearsay all right okay given
that he was able to uh sustain us to
hear say it is hearsay all right so you
so you determined Mr Wiggum
that by the fall of 2018
it was very likely that Mr Depp was not
going to be in Pirate six is that
correct
it's a two-pronged answer my perspective
because there was really two individuals
involved in that decision I would say
Jerry Bruckheimer and Sean Bailey Jerry
Bruckheimer in the fall of 2018 really
wanted Johnny and that next film and
Sean was non-committal as you said and
Mr Berkheimer made it clear to you that
Mr Bailey was the one who gets to decide
because he's Disney right
ultimately and he also wanted to be the
tip of the spear to really try to
convince John
thank you thank you
do you recall having your deposition
taken on January 20 2021
okay
Michelle please thank
you I'm going to ask you to turn to page
44 and Mr Wiggum you were under oath at
the time of this deposition correct
correct yes yes line 10
this is Page 44 line 10.
the question do you recall approximately
when in 2018
you inferred from Mr your discussion
with Mr Bailey that the likelihood of Mr
Depp being in Pirate six was knock high
or was going away
and your answer at that time was if
memory serves me the latter part of 2018
Maybe
question when you say ladder is that any
time from August to December or what are
you thinking answer I would say fall you
know maybe you know October November
December in that area do you recall
giving that testimony under oath at that
time
I I do now that I see it yes okay
in fact there quite a few things going
on earlier in 2018 that might have had a
bit of an a impact on Mr Depp's
reputation would you agree
if you it might help if you refresh your
recollection sure sure but and before I
go there though I think you said that
the reason it was so catastrophic for Mr
Depp for the op-ed was because it was a
first person account
of Johnny right
do you remember saying that
yes okay wasn't it a first person to
count when Ms heard filed for the tro
in 2016.
so that that would have predated any
relationship I had to Johnny so I had no
knowledge of that okay so you don't know
whether it was catastrophic then
it I I if you're asking me my opinion on
on something I don't know I can form an
opinion right now uh it's a court
document and
probably a little different than an
op-ed in the Washington Post
um but I would agree it's not a now that
I'm
forming an opinion that it's not a great
headline when you read the op-ed did you
read it online or did you read it in the
actual post paper
well let's pull up plaintiff's exhibit
two
does this refresh your recollection
very hard for me to see it is that is
that just the paper can we we're going
to try to scroll in a little bit more
again just you can help me I is that the
paper yes article yes that's the
Washington Post
so
what's the question sorry do you re does
this help refresh your recollection of
whether you saw it in print or whether
you saw it online
it does not but I'll tell you that I did
not typically
pick up the Washington Post you know
okay and so while we're sitting if you
can just for a second uh you're saying
that then two years ago IBK oops I
better not do that
clear that one then two years ago I
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse that's this first person
from Ms heard that's catastrophic for Mr
Depp is that your testimony
my testimony is that it reads like a
victim statement from someone involved
to the recipient and
it became a yes a bit of a
death nail catastrophic thing for Mr
Depp in the Hollywood Community
all right well let's go to let's pull up
defendants exhibit 99
now there was in fact
an article published in the Sun
newspaper by Dan Wooten the
editor-in-chief
on April 27 2018 do you recall that
now that I'm looking at it does that
refreshes your recollection and in fact
this article
calls Mr Depp a wife beater does it not
objection hearsay
I'll allow it for them
uh you know what I can't I can't see the
print even with these glasses but uh all
right well we'll I'll take your word for
it
well the the title here is how can JK
Rowling be genuinely happy casting wife
beater Johnny Depp in the new Fantastic
Beast film objection here
I love that
yeah
okay
you're and I'd like to move the
admission of this exhibit I think at
this point it's not offered to prove the
truth of the matter asserted but it's
going to offer he's testified to
comparisons of other articles he he's
he's testifying to the impact of the
op-ed I think it's In fairness we should
be able to put this in and be able to
make the comparisons it's clearly
hearsayer yeah
sustain the objection okay well let's go
to
the third page now let's go to the
fourth page so it has
A5 I think is what I'm trying to get to
so it says paragraph seven
so do you recall that it says in here uh
objection here save on it
Mr Wiggum
the article also had pictures did it not
I don't recall do you recall whether it
had a picture of Ms heard
Jackson here say you're on it I love
that
can we go to
eighth page
I'm showing you the picture right now
does that refresh your recollection your
honor uh hearsay lack of foundation out
loud
it it doesn't speak to my
impression of when I read it or how I
read it but
but all right and in fact it shows
bruises on it doesn't it on Ms heard's
face objection lack of foundation
overruled
so that would be what I think yes okay
now Mr Depp
filed the lawsuit
against the Sun newspaper and against
Dan Wooten for this article correct
I believe so June 13 2018
let's pull up one five nine nine
defendants 1599
does this refresh your recollection
Jackson here say your honor
I'm uh just for refreshing my collection
out loud
uh
uh just so I understand the question
you're asking does it refresh a memory
that Johnny followed against the sun yes
and Dan Wooten
on June 13 2018
sure okay now that I'm looking at it all
right and he did so in the UK in the
high court of justice correct
I believe so yeah you would know better
than that okay and if we can just turn
to page nine and do you recall that Mr
Depp alleged that that article had
caused him serious harm to his personal
and professional reputation
Jackson hearsay calls for speculation
to take a look at paragraph 11
and let me see if I can get your glasses
okay thank you very much
is there a way to even make that screen
bigger on mine I wish I was I had better
glasses for more technologically they
can make it a little bigger but I think
that's about as far as I'm going to try
to highlight it here so that that might
help you a little bit let me switch the
color but
so do you recall that Mr Depp alleged
that the article by in the Sun newspaper
by Dan Wooten had caused serious harm to
the claimant's personal and professional
reputation
if you're asking me I don't recall it I
was not involved in that case at all uh
I'm able to read
what's in front of me but you don't
recall it and you don't recall if that
had any impact on on Disney in 2018.
objection asked an answer I'll sustain
the objection next question all right do
you recall that Mr Depp also alleged
that he was caused significant distress
and embarrassment by the publication of
that article
in that case all right my memory of that
was it was a a tabloid so and the
lawyers were hanging all right Michelle
you can take that down thank you now
there was a trial in the UK was there
not on Mr Depp's claims of libel against
Dan Wooten and the Sun
I believe so and it was in July of 2020
was it not
I don't remember the date actually all
right and what it lasted three weeks do
you recall that
I don't but I'll take your word for it
do you recall there being an enormous
amount of publicity surrounding that
trial
objection calls for speculation like a
foundation he said he did thank you I'm
sorry Mr Wiggum you said you did recall
that asked and answered I'll love it
I remember there being depressed around
it yes ma'am okay and in fact uh do you
recall that Mr Depp gave testimony for
four days
not
do you recall that Ms heard gave
testimony for four days
I I don't recall any specific specific
memory of who testified for how long or
any any details within the case do you
recall there being many many witnesses
testifying at that case on that case
I think I'd revert to my answer just now
okay and the press that surrounded that
case do you recall it being focusing on
things like Mr Debb's drug and alcohol
use
same answer do you recall there being
the video the kitchen video being shown
repeatedly objection your honor may we
approach sure
I think my last question was do you
recall there being a lot of publicity
surrounding Mr Depp's alcohol and drug
use
I think I answered that right that's
right I was on the video the kitchen
video do you recall there being that the
kitchen video being played pretty
repeatedly in the Press
no I don't do you recall
a lot of pictures of Ms heard reflecting
bruises Cuts injuries
I I think just to be clear I I don't
recall anything that was going on within
the case I was always consumed with
next film and TV opportunities and that
was being handled by the lawyers
it's my memory
just have a couple more to ask you on
this do you recall there being
allegations of at least 14 incidents of
domestic violence against Ms heard in
that trial
same answer now could we bring up
exhibit number one again plaintiffs
now Mr Wiggum do you know who wrote
Amber Heard I spoke up against sexual
violence and faced our culture's wrath
this has to change
you're talking about the title yes
I wouldn't say that I to me it I would
have assumed it was misheard
you assume but you don't know do you
I do not okay and
were you aware that there were also
three pleaded incidents of sexual
violence in the UK trial
against misheard by Mr Depp
no ma'am okay
now your testimony is you can take that
down no thank you
your testimony is that
since some point
in 2020
Mr Depp has not had any more movie
opportunities is that correct
since sorry
repeat the date when is the last time Mr
Depp had a movie opportunity
the last film that he shot
to the best of my memory all right and
in fact do you know whether the
uh the the article that was in the UK
the ensuing lawsuit that was brought by
Mr debb and the ensuing trial and all
the publicity do you know whether that
had any impact on Mr Depp's career
objection compound
do you know whether the collection of
all of those items I just listed had an
impact on Mr Depp's career
if remind me of the dates that you're
asking about
so so the answer I I take it is no you
don't know correct
I I'm just trying to make sure I give
you a correct answer so I understand the
question you referenced after 2020. okay
they are saying the article
was April of 2018.
the lawsuit was June of 2018.
the trial was July of 2020.
what opportunities has Mr Depp had since
July 2020
since July 2020
he has not done a film
thank you I have no further questions
all right redirect
good afternoon again Mr Wiggum uh do you
recall Ms bretahof asked you
questions about whether you ever
actually saw a document containing the
22 and a half million dollar deal for Mr
Depp for pirate six do you recall that
I do and do you recall when you were
trying to answer her question you said
you needed a little more context you
recall that
yes and would you please now provide the
jury that context so they can have a
fuller understanding of what your what
your testimony is
so often on a franchise movie when
you're dealing with big stars and you're
talking about future optional pictures
uh you engage
at the high level uh meaning the
president or the top of the studio to
get an understanding of what that deal
is going to going to be they then get
papered typically when I say papered
amended because it's like it's based on
the same contract usually that's been in
existence and it would get
sometimes we don't see paperwork or get
paperwork until the film is happening
and Mr Wiggum on a similar line
Miss bretahof to ask you some questions
about whether after this deal was done
it was starting to Trend badly with
respect to Disney and not so and and
what and still well with respect to Mr
Bruckheimer in the fall of 2018 do you
remember that testimony
I do
when was it that Disney made the final
decision as to whether Mr Depp would be
Empire six
you know sustain the objection I'll
sustain the objection next question
Mr wiggin it may have been trending
badly
as of that time but Disney had not gone
in
in the other direction correct
earlier
earlier was two days after
the op-ed
and and I was saying that Disney had
never
said that Johnny would not be in the
film as of that date and
my
it was my testimony is the exact same as
the deposition which is it was trending
back badly in the late fall on behalf of
Disney but I was but Jerry Bruckheimer
and I were lobbying to make it happen
and so we had hope and it became clear
to me in early 2019
that it was over
thank you very Mr thank you very much Mr
wigam no further questions all right
thank you is this witness subject to
recall
yes your honor all right Mr Wigan this
is your subject to recall you're still
subject to the rule on Witnesses so you
cannot discuss your testimony with
anybody and you cannot watch any of the
trials okay sir
all right but you're free for today
thank you all right thank you thank you
all right your next Witness
your honor before we call the next
witness may we approach briefly okay
sure
three of them
you selling square or affirm testified
previously in this case the penalty of
law yes
good how you doing sir good afternoon
you can sit down sir that's fine
good afternoon Mr Marks uh good
afternoon would you please State your
full name for the record
Richard Edward marks and Mr Marks where
do you live I live in Hollywood
would you tell us a little bit about
your educational background sir
I'm I'm a product of the
um
public school system in Los Angeles
and I went to UCLA undergraduate and I'm
a graduate of UCLA School of Law
when did you graduate from UCLA School
of Law I graduated in
1973 and I've been an officer of the
courts since then almost 50 years
where do you work
I work at my own Law Firm Richard Marks
and Associates
what is Richard Marx and Associates
uh it is a transactional entertainment
Law Firm and we represent individuals
writers directors actors books
but authors but mainly we represent
producers who are developing a product
if you will to be produced and then
exploited on television features
streaming things like that
when you say a transactional law firm
what do you mean by that uh what I do is
make deals they're transactions I'm a
deal guy so my whole practice all these
decades has been about getting to yes
how do you make a deal and then how do
you get it documented so people sign it
and then are able it's clear enough that
it can be administered and people can
know what to do after you've made the
deal
[Music]
specifically what types of clients do
you work with
well as I said
I work with all kinds of clients but the
the my bigger clients and the bulk of my
practice is representing producers who
produce they develop and they produce
content for exploitation
yeah I've been working for a long time
with
ITV which is a a huge British company
with Worldwide
reach in entertainment they produce
the voice love Island and right now I've
done all the development legal work on a
mini series that's about to shoot in
France and the England starring Michael
Douglas as Benjamin Franklin it's based
on a novel that we optioned I helped
them option years ago then scripts were
written for the eight hours then Michael
Douglas was engaged the director was
engaged and I do all those contracts and
that's ITV
um another one of my uh big clients is
Village Roadshow they're an Australian
company they
they partner with Warner Brothers and
they produce movies like Matrix
Aquaman Scooby-Doo uh right now I am
working on a television series for them
doing the legal production and and
before that it was development the
production legal work on a reboot of the
old college bowl uh show where two
colleges come together with teams and
answer questions and and here they're
going to win scholarships and the hosts
are Peyton Manning and Eli Manning
that's currently what I'm working on for
Village Road Show
any other clients and I would say my my
third big client is a company called uh
media rights MRC
and they they produce movies and and TV
shows recently I've I've done a lot of
work for them uh they are finishing up a
a mini series that I'm doing the legal
work on for Apple starring Billy crudup
uh we just finished a mini series for
them called terminal list with Chris
Pratt uh that's for Amazon
uh and and we recently finished
a mini series doing the legal deal
making for MRC
um on a show called the shrinkneck store
which is aired uh it
started Will Ferrell and Paul Rudd
and then I I you know I can't leave out
uh my longest client which is the
producers of uh Bosch uh for uh Amazon
uh
it's got to be nine ten years ago when
we went into Amazon they had never
produced a series
and we negotiated a deal for uh Michael
Conley's book series uh and uh we cast
Titus well over as Bosch they wouldn't
order a series they would only order a
pilot and
now uh in the next few days
what I call the eighth season but which
is the first season of the spin-off will
uh be available on IMBd TV instead of on
Amazon but Amazon owns IMDb TV
uh and um and we're in right now writing
the uh the ninth season so I've had this
long run with this uh one particular
series
can you tell the jury a little bit about
the types of deals that you work on for
these clients
foreign
well when you think of um of a of a
series or a motion picture
and you see the credits there's hundreds
of of credits there and everyone of
those people you have to make a deal
with them and you have to pay for it so
that they they sign it and you know what
to pay them and what what is there a
guild involved a union uh you know what
are their services and
um what I do is
all of that Soup To Nuts uh many times
sometimes I work with in-house counsel
or other attorneys and we split up the
work but basically uh you know you want
to produce a movie or a show you you
might option A book I do that deal you
might hire a writer then you might get a
director then then a line producer a upm
for A.D then you start hiring your cast
then you start making location deals
then you start renting equipment and
props and getting releases for
photos you might show or for people who
might end up on camera
and then when you're done shooting
you're making deals for
merchandising and deals with
Distributors and uh in the old days it
was might have been for a DVD or for
merchandising a doll
and so it's really
what I do is make deals and all deals uh
I've been doing it for almost 50 years
but they're all the same they have
elements of time money credit rights and
perks and I have approached deals that
way so that I've
made myself relevant when I started out
there were three networks and big
studios
and attorneys said well I'm a TV lawyer
I'm a feature lawyer I just said I'm a
transactional lawyer and so I've been
able to adapt and make deals with
Netflix quibby YouTube uh you know you
name it I've I've made deals I mean I
recently made a deal with uh Hellman's
mayonnaise for an actress who's going to
be an influencer for them on the web and
it was you know hype it was a good
Payday for this actress but
that's the way I look at deals I'm a
deal maker and that's my practice
marks you testified that you
at the East 50 years
how did you get started in the internet
history
I get started in the entertainment
industry by being born in Hollywood and
it's our it's our town industry if you
will
and uh I've always been interested in it
and uh when I went to UCLA I took all
the film classes there were
uh and when I went to UCLA law school it
was by Design because number one I
couldn't afford the the the big law
school so UCLA was a public school it
was virtually free I went to UCLA law
school because if you want to practice
entertainment law in Hollywood
those you go to UCLA or USC those are
the the schools where you kind of create
your contacts and your your network
uh and at UCLA they had some of the best
professors who taught entertainment Law
related subjects so I took copyright
trademark uh entertainment contracts if
you will I took Everything Entertainment
related
um
and and that's how I kind of built the
foundation for then my afterlaw school
career
what did you do after you graduated from
Law School
well I um I wanted to do entertainment
transaction law but
I realized I could earn a little bit
more money if I went into entertainment
litigation uh suing over copyrights and
trademarks and so I took uh the highest
paying job out of that I could get out
of law school and was
in 1973 and I I did I P litigation
disputes over copyrights trademarks uh
disputes over rights things like that
and I was a low-level litigator
um doing depositions or motions uh
certainly not sitting at the you know
examining Witnesses except it might be
in a deposition
and and I and I did that uh for about it
was my first year out of Law School
what did you do after
that well after that I I kind of made a
decision that uh being a litigator
wasn't for me
uh that I wanted to make deals that I
wanted my career to be about getting to
yes
and that involved a lot of uh you know
conflict sometimes but the goal was to
get to yes so that um both the parties
could work together because the goal was
working together and creating the TV
show not making the deal the deal makers
had to step away so that you closed the
deal and then people could live with
that deal and um so I went to a a
transactional law firm and um uh I was
there a couple years and and I made
deals
what kind of projects did you work on
when you transitioned into that deal
making role
well this is um you know uh
mid 1970s and this law firm uh uh was
taught if you will and some of my
classmates were there that's how I got
the job I had to take a cut and pay to
go there
uh and
um I I'll never forget I'm the second
chair attorney
in a big conference room at Fox and
we're trying to close a deal for our
young client George Lucas to make a film
called Star Wars a
western Space movie and fox would not
give us the budget or the salary he
wanted
and this is the God's honest truth we
said okay give us the merchandising
and famously they gave us the
merchandising because they didn't think
there was value there
and that's how much our business has
changed
while I was at uh that my first
transactional firm we also worked for a
client his name is Sylvester Stallone
he his claim to fame is that he was a
character actor but he had written a
script that all the major Stars wanted
to play they wanted to play the role
Rocky and he said I will not sell this
script unless I play Rocky and no one
was happy about that and the deal we
made was uh he got to play the role but
it was a very low budget and he hardly
had a dressing room he hardly had any
perks he wasn't happy about it but we
were able to make up for that in the
deals for Rocky two three
and and and that's the type of deals it
was we at that entertainment
transactional firm we weren't
representing
um uh major companies if you will we
were representing artists uh writers
directors Talent like I'm uh you know
individuals we weren't representing the
companies I do now like ITV or Village
Road Show
how long were you at that law firm
I was at that firm for um
a couple years
what did you do after that
after that I made a decision that
um I I
wanted to go in-house where the
full-time business was making a you know
product and
I was very tied to production and uh and
I was I wanted to move away from law
firms at that moment and my first
in-house job was for the Ziegler
discount agency
which was one of the Premier literary
agencies in town we we represented
writers and books and the states of
books and at that time in
late 70s early 80s if you wanted to hire
a writer or a book
or option of book
there were three places you went
he went to Swifty which he's kind of
famous swiffy lazar's Oscar parties or
you went to
Swanee H.L Swanson or you went to Ziggy
and I worked for Ziggy
did you work for any other companies in
in house capacity as a deal maker
oh yeah yeah I I you know with Ziggy uh
we made deals for the book The Princess
Bride we we did a lot of we worked for
William Goldman who that was his book
and his screenplay and uh you know it
was a fabulous experience but that firm
was bought by
um uh ICM a much bigger agency and then
I moved to Paramount that's what I where
I next went and at Paramount I um uh was
the attorney on the series cheers and
the series Family Ties which was the the
break for the the young son Michael J
fox
um
and then I did something because I have
never
said I'm just a TV lawyer I'm a deal
maker I get to yes
and it's sort of unheard of but I moved
from Network television doing the deals
for church and family times I moved to
features of Paramount
uh because you can earn a little more
money and features uh and I was married
and uh I I had a child
and and it features I was assigned to do
the development and production work for
a producer who's in this case Jerry
Bruckheimer
uh and um
and I also uh
served they had an overall deal with
Eddie Murphy so I I did his the legal
work in his films like Beverly Hills Cop
uh Coming to America things like that
and I and I was a Paramount about four
years
where'd you go after Paramount
uh after Paramount I got this
opportunity to head up business and
legal Affairs in the feature division
for Jerry weintraub's Studio Jerry was
famous at the time for Karate Kid at
Ocean's 11 and
he represented uh you know Elvis and
Frank Sinatra in music and John Denver
but this was his Motion Picture company
and uh and I uh was in features
and um
uh at we we made a film called Troop
Beverly Hills which is starring Shelley
Long
uh we made another film the big blue we
acquired a film Library he was
positioning himself to be a major
company until he went bankrupt and that
was one of his only failures
where'd you go after that uh after Jerry
Weintraub I went to Disney and I filled
in for a year for the head of legal and
features who was on maternity leave and
taking a family leave and so I uh headed
up legal on films like Dick Tracy
Madonna was in that uh
Rocketeer and other live-action film but
what I really remember about my time at
Disney is they were revamping the um
animation department and they wanted to
make a different kind of Disney animated
film
and part of it in the old days Disney
animated films
um the um the voices weren't advertised
they weren't the stars of the movie
Disney was the star or Dumbo was a star
but the voices were hardly known
and we broke that mold and it was the
the first deal where we
paid real money to someone to do a voice
was a deal I made with
Robin Williams to voice Aladdin and it
changed the whole history of Disney and
feature animation I worked on Beauty and
the Beast and and it was a it was a
tremendous experience to be involved
with them
after you worked at Disney did you
continue to fill in-house deal making
roles yeah I continued my in-house Road
even in the world that I could see was
consolidating and it was going to be
more and more difficult to stay in-house
um after Disney I went to a company
called media Home Entertainment
and they put up money for films
and for their investment they got the
VHS cassette rights so the media home
entertainment was one of the producers
investors in the Nightmare and Elm
Street series and blue velvet and what
they got was the right to sell video
cassettes they also
manufactured and sold the Jane Fonda
videos or the NFL videos and
it was a it was a great business except
the studios realized are we crazy why
are we letting another company sell
video we should keep that in-house
and so I was not only had a legal but I
was on the board of directors and we
sold the company to to Fox so that they
could take in the assets and eliminate a
a competitor
where'd you go after that
um
after media home entertainment I went to
a company called Kushner lock it was
very it was a time in the business there
were hundreds of independent producing
companies because the networks couldn't
produce for themselves there were laws
preventing it
and Christian Locke we produced
Pinocchio with Jonathan Taylor Thomas we
produced a small movie called freeway it
was Reese Witherspoon's one of her first
roles and
it was um I was there for eight years it
was a good long run uh until uh they
as all those independent companies
ultimately did not all most they would
he they went bankrupt after eight years
what did you do after
uh now you can see I'm still chasing the
in-house uh world I went to a company
nelvana they were a
um a Canadian animation company but they
had this big office in La I headed up
business legal we manufactured made
produced
animated uh television series like Care
Bears and and Merchandising also uh
Babar big bear little bear
all sorts of animated subjects and
Merchandising deals and cartoons if you
will and then that Canadian company
closed the LA office and moved back to
Canada I didn't want to move back to
Canada and so my last in-house situation
I went to a universal network television
and I did business and legal Affairs on
uh just shoot me a television series
a series starring Josh Brolin called Mr
Sterling it was kind of patterned on Mr
Smith Goes to Washington
um and at the same time I was at uh
Universal network television I I
consulted uh with uh Nickelodeon
features and um
I um uh I I I helped them sort of build
out their their feature uh
products
they were on the Paramount lot I had
been at Paramount for a long time and we
worked on Films such as SpongeBob the
animated film
and then when when that Consulting ended
and NBC came in and bought Universal
that you know ended my my job at
Universal and I made the decision I
would go back and be a a lawyer at a law
firm
types of work were you doing when you
went back to the law firms
when I went back to the law firm I um I
did
a lot of you know I worked on their
clients uh and uh I I helped a financier
Robert schillerman in effect by the
American Idol brand I worked with a
Barry Gordy's company
trying to turn some of his world into
theatrical plays I worked with the Nat
King Cole estate trying to to do things
so it was a lot of reality I remember I
worked with Walt J Walter Thompson and
they um they were
in effect creating advertising
opportunity branding and then the one
that's fixed in my mind is I I help you
know George Foreman Market things so
that he made a deal to be the face of a
thing called the George Foreman grill
and
and it was a it was a it's a good
practice
Mr Mark she testified that you now are
at a law firm called Richard Marx and
Associates when did you start that firm
well after the firm I just told you
about was called Greenberg trial rig
it's a large International firm I moved
to a firm called the point media in
um
2006 and I was there for 14 years
doing much the same work that I do now
and then in 2020 right at the start of
the pandemic I went out on my own
informed Richard Marx and Associates
over the course of a career what if any
changes have you observed in the deal
making space in the entertainment
industry
well
before I got involved in the business
most deals for writers were how much
money per week and how many weeks
when when I got into the business it was
already more complicated but through my
decades all that's happened has gotten
more and more complicated still the
Essential Elements of time money credit
um
uh perks uh money uh whatever but it's
gotten more complicated you had to deal
with merchandising you had to deal with
sequels you had to deal with all sorts
of derivative Works video games you name
it uh you know publicity promotion it
all expanded so that making a deal
that might have been you know simple
30 years before now was a major
production and uh you know lawyers
became integral you couldn't get it do a
deal without someone who was going to
dive into the the boilerplate and make
sure that it was right
your honor I'm about
I'm about a little bit I don't know if
you
know if now for lunch or if you could
approach us for a moment
thank you
foreign
before we take lunch plaintiff would
move in Mr Marks as an expert in the
entertainment industry all right
objection
all right so moved all right ladies and
gentlemen we'll go ahead and take our
our lunch then uh please do not talk to
me anybody and don't do any outside
research we'll see you back in an hour
okay thank you
Mr Sparks if you just stay there for a
second sir
stay there for a second
sir
since you're in the middle of your
testimony you cannot talk to anybody
about your testimony at this time
including any lawyers or Mr death okay
sir all right all right we'll be back
and we'll be back at let's make it two
o'clock okay all right thank you
foreign
thank you
thank you
thank you
excuse me
it's sort of popping my mind
popping the mic too close to it
was I
foreign
foreign
all right are you ready for the jury
okay
foreign
thank you Hunter
Mr Marks what work were you asked to do
in this case
uh I was asked to
bring my years of experience in the
entertainment industry
uh and look at the the damage that the
op-ed of
2018
uh created in Johnny Depp's career in
his life and his reputation
what work did you do to determine
whether Mr Depp's reputation had been
damaged by the op-ed
well again I I view the op-ed and the
Fallout through almost 50 years in the
business and what I did was I read the
pleadings in the case the deposition
transcripts the Articles uh
uh the pleadings
all of the the
paperwork in this case which is
voluminous
based on the analysis you've done and
your expertise in the entertainment
industry have you formed any opinions in
this case
yes what generally speaking what is your
opinion my general opinion is that the
op-ed uh
damaged uh uh Mr Depp created a a
canceled situation if you will uh harmed
his reputation and his ability to get
work and yeah Hollywood industry hold on
sir yes I thought could we approach sure
Mr Marks do you have experience working
with companies looking to engage actors
to Market or advertise their products
yes and what's that experience
well virtually every company I I work
for uh they are engaging actors to
advertise their products
most of the time those products are TV
shows or streaming series or feature
films
that all involve products spin-offs and
derivatives and sometimes they are just
uh
products
and spokespeople getting together
but yes I have experience in in a hiring
a star to be the face of your product
what types of things do companies
consider when they're looking at using
actors in their marketing or advertising
well as you can imagine they consider
reputation this is a capitalist society
and they're looking to make money they
want to add value to their investment
they want actors who have reputations
that will bring eyeballs to the screen
bodies in the seats they're looking for
added value not negativity
do you have experience negotiating
agreements for actors to play a certain
role in a film
oh yes as I explained I I negotiate
deals with actors to play roles in films
and
what's the significance of the actor in
the starring role in the context of a
feature film
the um the actor in the starring role
becomes the face of the film The Product
the series
that actor is synonymous
with the product and again in hiring
that actor or actress you
want a reputation that supports uh the
value that you've spent on creating the
product
uh
you might say the Pirates of the
Caribbean is Johnny Depp and vice versa
that's this importance of hiring a star
what aspects of an actor's reputation
might impact their ability to get hired
by brands or Studios
well again on the other side of the coin
yeah you um you wouldn't want to hire an
actor who has negativity uh following
them you wouldn't want to pay to
actually bring your brand down your
movie and uh
so that's very important and especially
in the The Last Five Years uh uh with
the metoo movement uh you wouldn't want
uh negativity
uh hiring an actor
Who quote unquote had been canceled
are there um is there anything in
particular that might prevent an actor
from getting hired by a brand or a
studio
well I mean we're talking about illegal
activity uh a criminal record but right
now uh the the Pinnacle of negativity uh
in Hollywood is uh being accused of
domestic abuse sexual uh abuse violence
and what we've seen is almost
immediately
terminations and cancellations
to for for the investors to the people
who create that product to to move away
from that negativity
I think you mentioned the metoo movement
um what's your understanding of what the
metoo movement is
my understanding of the metoo movement
is that
uh
finally a society is listening to the uh
victim giving the the victim of uh
domestic abuse
sexual abuse the benefit of the doubt
and there has been a shift in our
society
from not doing that to now
the victim gets the benefit of the doubt
until there's too much doubt
and to me that's the metoo movement one
person can come forward and accuse
Harvey Weinstein and another person can
come forward in another and another
that's the meet you part of it but they
get the benefit of the doubt whereas
in the past uh
the the victim didn't have that benefit
what impact has the metoo movement
movement Hollywood conducts business
it um
in my many decades in the business
Hollywood has has changed and morphed
but
never as quickly
as to respond to the metoo movement that
started in 2017.
when I started in the business
every contract
for an actor or someone involved in the
movie had a morals Clause that you did
certain things and you could be fired
for it uh they wanted to protect their
brand
in the before the metoo movement that
moral's Clause was fading out
uh
people with leverage people said wait a
second you just can't get rid of us
because you think this or that
with the metoo movement Harvey Weinstein
Bill Cosby if you will the morals Clause
has come back and it is a demanded
feature in every uh entertainment uh
employment agreement because the studios
want that verbiage they want those
rights so that they can act quickly and
decisively
when there is a a claim
Mr Marks do you have any experience
working on a project where an actor was
accused of domestic abuse or sexual
violence yes what was that experience
I did um some of the production legal
work on a film called
all the money in the world uh it was
about the life of the Gettys J Paul
Getty and Jay Paul Getty was played by
Uh Kevin Spacey
he acted in the part he finished his
role he was paid and then
these metoo accusations came out
and immediately my client in conjunction
with Sony they made a decision to take
him out of the movie
uh and we uh Christopher Plummer was
hired they re-shot all his scenes
and seamlessly cut them in uh to the
movie and if you see that all the money
in the world you won't know that Kevin
Spacey was ever in it
so I had that personal experience and
then coincidentally when that happened
I was also doing work for MRC which
produces House of Cards uh and
a very successful series and and he was
the star of it and he was immediately
cut out and everything was redone
to to get rid of the the the notion that
Hollywood would support an abuser after
the the metoo movement
um and then I because I was in the mix
of all of it I also know that Kevin
Spacey had completed another movie for
Netflix
um and unlike uh all the money in the
world they couldn't reshoot it and it
sits on the Shelf a movie about Gore
Vidal that was finished but has never
seen the LIE today
what's your understanding of why these
companies wanted Kevin Spacey removed
from those projects
can you repeat the question
what's your understanding of why these
companies wanted Kevin Spacey removed
from those projects
these companies as I've said they want
they wanted Kevin Spacey removed because
it didn't want the negativity they they
want anyone removed so that
they can get a return on their
investment in our society so that they
are not seen as being in the old
generation where women were not given
the benefit of the doubt we're a victims
were not given the benefit of the doubt
and uh
there a switch has been turned uh and
and
certainly by 2017.
are there certain types of companies
that are particularly sensitive to these
kinds of allegations made by women in
light of metoo movement
well I would say
the bigger the company the bigger the
budgets
they're all sensitive
but at the Pinnacle of sensitivity are
the family friendly companies like
Disney they're particularly sensitive uh
not in a general way but in a very
specific way
Mr Marks are you familiar with the op-ed
misheard published in the Washington
Post on December 18 2018. yes what's
your understanding of how that op-ed was
received in Hollywood
my understanding of how that op-ed was
received in Hollywood I'm sorry sir is
this his personal understanding his
expert understanding it it seems like if
it's a personal understanding it's not
relevant but
I'm asking Mr March based on his nearly
50 years in the entertainment objection
thank you
uh
as I've said before I am a member of the
Hollywood Community
that op-ed
uh for the first time is in a a
mainstream publication called The
Washington Post this is a flagship
Journal if you will of American news
we're not talking about a trade paper
we're not talking about a rag we're
talking about the Washington Post and it
it is geared to Hollywood it says two
years ago when I was getting my divorce
Amber Heard is saying uh I I was the
abuser and you didn't Hollywood you you
stood up for my uh abuser not for sure
now he's mischaracterizing the document
I think he's he's expressing his
understanding of how that was personal
overall objection go ahead
what I'm saying is Hollywood got the uh
the the subject matter the loud of the
of the op-ed loud and clear
Amber Heard was calling out Hollywood
for supporting uh uh since night since
2016 supporting her abuser and uh uh she
felt the wrath of Hollywood she was
calling them out to do something in the
Washington Post and
um on the eve of her biggest uh film a
big film for Hollywood the publicity
machine was in high gear there was lots
of publicity and uh news out there this
was the height of of her Fame and she
used it at that moment to call Hollywood
out they uh in my opinion as a member of
Hollywood they heard uh that plea loud
and clear uh and
um uh it also got her publicity for her
movie uh you know I don't think that
that
in my perception of people in Hollywood
didn't see that as a coincidence that
date and
um
so yeah in in Hollywood I think um uh
the the message was received that she
was sending
Mr Depp's reputation in Hollywood with
respect to whether or not he's on time
to his film sets
yes what's your understanding
Hollywood has a history of putting up
with major artists and major Stars
idiosyncratic behaviors
uh you know we've always had uh
Divas like Marilyn Monroe who would stay
in her trailer for half a day Johnny
Depp uh has a reputation of being Johnny
Depp and when you hire Johnny Depp you
get all of Johnny Depp and that includes
uh being late
and fortunately in Hollywood because of
the budgets and the and the box office
you can budget for for lateness you can
have second unit you can have other
shots uh you can you have padding in
budgets
you have insurance for for accidents but
Hollywood Knows Mr Depp's reputation and
uh
you know I heard someone say Hollywood
puts up with Diva and drugs uh they only
do that uh when uh it money's involved
and big stars are involved in and
Artistry is involved
Mr Marx
have an understanding of Mr Depp's
overall reputation in Hollywood prior to
the publication of the December 2018
op-ed
um
I would say that um
Johnny Depp was one of the few uh major
actors in Hollywood who managed to keep
most of his personal life personal
kept
himself uh shrouded if you will a bit
um
and his reputation you know preceded him
as a major artist in Hollywood
but what what also marked him uh in this
business is that
he
was congruent he was he was likable he
you know he he was uh uh you know one of
the one of the one of the guys and uh it
um uh I I never heard
any uh
complaints uh you know uh
if you will
do you have an opinion about the impact
of the publication of the op-ed on Mr
Depp's reputation in Hollywood
uh it's devastating it it's um it's it's
the type of claim to meet me too claim
of sexual violence domestic abuse that
has canceled a list of of uh of actors
uh krishnath recently I just read
something about Frank langella we know
uh
newscasters uh Les moonves ahead of ABC
CBS uh now Johnny Depp is in their ranks
it's it's devastating
I think you're on new further questions
all right cross-examination Mr nadelhoff
good afternoon
um you're right in this case is 975
dollars per hour is that right
that's correct and you've Char and
you've never charged that higher rate in
any other case isn't that right
I've I've charged near that amount but
but never that high correct that's
correct okay how much of your Char how
much have you received for this case
uh I'd have to look at my billing during
my deposition uh uh the the attorney who
deposed me asked me the same question I
said I would look it up I did during
lunch and then she never got back to it
again I don't remember how much it was
then and I don't have the figures uh now
and you don't know how many hours he
worked on this case
I would get uh again I'd be guessing and
I don't know if you want me to guess I
have a full-time transactional practice
this is a very small part of my practice
okay
okay now you said you worked for Disney
uh for less than a year right I worked
for Disney about a year yeah and that
was in 1990 right
uh yes so that was about that was 32
years ago yeah okay and you worked at
Greenberg trowering from 2004 to 2006 is
that right that's correct your leaving
was a mutual decision was it not yes
okay
um
now
Mr depsel has an endorsement deal with
uh Dior correct
I understand that yes okay and he's had
that endorsement deal since 2015 isn't
that right
uh I I believe he's had the endorsement
deal for a while and I think he still
has it right and Dior hasn't dropped Mr
dap correct
as far as I know Dior has not dropped
him all right and Mr Depp did not have a
contract for pirate six isn't that right
as far as I know there is no contract
for pirate six right and all the
documents you've looked at you looked at
all the documents in this case and
you've not seen a contract for pirate
sex right
that's my memory of the documents there
was no contract for pirates and in all
the documents you looked at you didn't
see a text saying Mr Depp got the
contract for pirate six for 22.5 million
right
objection asked and answered
overruled
I I didn't see paperwork on an agreement
for uh car Pirates of the Caribbean six
so not an email not a text not any
written document about pirate six
correct objection ask an answer I'll
sustain that objection next question
mm-hmm
and you don't know one way or the other
whether Mr Depp will be in Pirates of
Caribbean six you don't have a crystal
ball is that right
objection speculation
he's an expert I love it yeah go ahead
overall go ahead you can answer sir
well as an expert of course I don't have
a crystal ball but as an expert uh uh
I think Disney will do everything
possible to try to put him back in
Pirates but not under uh This Cloud
God you would agree that there was
negative publicity about Mr death before
the op-ed correct
yes you know that misheard made her
accusations public starting in May of
2016 right
yes and and Hollywood knew about that
right yes okay
and Mr Depp still had movies after May
of 2016 right
yes okay
now you would agree that there was
negative publicity about Mr Depp being
publicly drunk before the op-ed correct
there was I I agree with the proposition
that there was negative publicity before
the op-ed the op-ed was something
different
and you agree it as in in 2014 there was
an article in the guardian that said
apparently drunk Johnny Depp cut off at
Hollywood film awards ceremony would you
agree with that
again I I don't remember reading the the
guardian and I don't remember that
particular incident but I I'll take you
at your word and you were you remember
in looking through all the documents
that you saw an article that Johnny Depp
allegedly showed up drunk to movie
premiere Reports say right that was in
2017.
I I think I've testified that uh
there there is certainly Johnny Depp
behavior and and uh negativity out there
yes
and what and that a family that a family
that a family Production Studio like
Disney wouldn't want to be associated
with correct
uh again you're talking about a very
specific uh uh you know
um series of five films that are in
billions of dollars uh and there is a
line in Hollywood as I've said they'll
put up with divas and drugs to make
money uh but now we've drawn a line uh
in Hollywood at uh the um uh domestic
and sexual abuse and looking through the
documents you saw the articles in June
of 2018 that said vodka for breakfast
72-hour drug binges and spending sprees
that beggar belief you saw that
again I I know these articles exist I
know they're not in the Washington Post
I don't know what article you're
referring to who wrote it uh you know
what publication it was in but I know
that those articles exist and you'd
agree that before the op-ed Mr death had
a run of movie flops wouldn't you agree
every actor has uh you know ups and
downs Mr Depp is his career has been
decades long you would agree that in in
January of 2015 there was an article
that said Johnny Depp is on his way to
becoming the most overpaid actor in
Hollywood
again you'd have to show me the article
but I don't doubt that some commentator
trying to trade on being a smarty pants
wrote that and you'd agree that there
was another article in 2015 that says
quote has Johnny Depp become Hollywood's
biggest joke
I don't know Netflix has a whole
festival going now Netflix is a joke and
you'd agree that there is an article in
Business Insider from 2015 that says
Johnny Depp has his fifth box office
bomb in a row
if that's what it said it said are you
just going to keep reading this well I
mean this is Mr depth's reputation
that's what you're talking about in
terms of in terms of Hollywood correct
and in 2016 December of 2016 there's a
quote there's an article that says quote
Johnny Depp is Hollywood's most overpaid
actor for the second year in a row did
you recall reading that
and it was out written by the second uh
underpaid actor or and you would agree
that before the op-ed there was a
negative publicity for Mr Depp about
assassinating president Trump you agree
no I missed that one you didn't see an
article in the New York Times that said
Johnny Depp flirts with idea of trump
assassination then apologizes again
talks with the irony and uh Panache and
uh I don't particularly remember that I
have a lot of stuff in front of me
Disney wouldn't want to be Disney
wouldn't want to be involved with
somebody who's calling for the
assassination of the president would it
I'm sure after those articles uh Johnny
Depp was involved in major Studio
project do you know one way or the other
whether Mr Depp was involved in major
Studio Projects after June 23 2017.
uh I I
think uh again I I haven't quoted his uh
IMDb DB page to memory but he was in um
uh an animated film called Sherlock
gnomes I think it was released uh
Paramount is one of the producers I
think it was released in 2017. would you
agree that before the op-ed there was
negative publicity for Mr death about
punching a crew member on a film set
I I heard about that so those people who
work in Hollywood the Mr death edit
accusation of assault correct
I I I I heard about it yes and would you
agree that there were stories about Mr
depth drinking heavily on the set of
pirates five
uh
there were lots of stories that came out
and I'm sure that uh was one of them and
those stories came out in 2016 and 2017
before the op-ed right
um
again you'd have to show me a timeline
but I'll take your word that there were
articles uh written in various Rags or
or trade public and New York Times Iraq
is that is that what you're saying no
I'm not saying the New York Times is a
rag what I'm saying is
at the height of the metoo movement we
have this op-ed uh directed at Hollywood
and in in the Hollywood I know the rest
of the stuff is background noise now and
Pirates 5 did not make as much money in
the box office as the prior Pirates
movies did isn't that true
uh that's true it only it made about 800
uh million they made less so than the
first four correct yeah and any company
any company would want to have a a box
office hit that made 800 million dollars
now let's can you put up exhibit uh
defendants exhibit uh 99 please
you blow it up
now you said the metoo movement started
in 2017 is that is that what you're
saying
um it actually started long before that
but it picked up steam to the to the
what we now call the metoo movement in
2017. okay and do you recognize this
article from Dan Wooten it says how can
JK Rowling be genuinely happy casting
wife beater Johnny Depp and the new
Fantastic Beasts film
yes this article is in um
uh the UK's son which I came to
prominence by uh publishing uh topless
women on page three
and the article came out in April on
April 27 2018 correct
I'll I I haven't skimmed through this
but I'll I'll take your your word for it
and
it's I think what you're trying to say
was that the sun was a rag so no one
would pay any attention to it is that
what you're trying to say
I'm I'm seeing the sun is the sun uh and
it's in UK and what this article is is a
is repeating stuff from 2016. repeating
all the stuff that you might say should
be all past history after the divorce
it's one one wooten's opinion in in a
newspaper that's claimed to fame as H3
women topless and yeah
sued the son over this right what's that
Mr def sued the sun in the UK about this
article right uh as far as I know he
wanted to uh clear his name that's right
Mr Depp that's that lawsuit occurred in
2020 correct it was tried in 2020.
uh
I believe so yeah and there were
accusations of abuse that came out based
on that lawsuit correct
as far as I know the accusations were
all old news and uh predated much
yeah I mean this is a 2018 article and
in 2020 they probably were rehashing it
and the old news that was coming out in
2018 that would also affect Mr Depp's
reputation correct
again I've tried to draw a line the the
line that Hollywood draws uh uh between
uh the metoo movement and uh starting in
2017 uh and the the
gossip and the the claims back and forth
I mean I there was there was also a
press about Amber Heard being an abuser
uh in those years uh there was also the
other side of the coin but the op-ed
that didn't mention Mr death at all and
didn't mention any accusations that
would happen to her that's what caused
Mr Depp reputational all his
reputational harm that's what you're
saying well I don't agree that this
article was not about they didn't
mentioned that's what I asked you uh
well the does she have another husband
who abused her but they didn't talk
about it did it talk at all about Mr
Depp's abuse objection your honor he's
tried to answer the
question you ask your question
the op-ed article didn't mention any
specific abuse by Mr Depp towards Amber
Heard correct
uh the only uh name is this is Amber
Heard telling her story that started in
2016 when she was domestically abused
and ignored
now
there were headlines about the UK trial
correct
I'm sure there were yes like
let's burn Amber text allegedly sent by
Johnny Depp about ex reading Court
I didn't hear you let's burn Amber text
allegedly sent by Johnny Depp about X
read in court
yeah and there's a headline from July
19th 2020 that said quote Hollywood
nervously awaits Fallout from explosive
Johnny Depp trial so Hollywood was
following the following the case correct
yeah when was that headline in 2020 20.
yeah I I look uh uh Johnny Depp is a
decades-long uh fixture in Hollywood and
people were were following something
across the pond you know we thought we
kind of got rid of the UK in 1776 but
they were still following it absolutely
I mean Mr Depp thought of enough about
this article
to have a three-week trial in the UK
correct objection calls for speculation
about what Mr debb thought I'll sustain
the objection next question there was a
three-week trial in the UK based on this
article by Dan Wooten correctly I think
I've said uh Mr Depp uh finally uh had
enough any any sued to clear his name
okay all right
yep you want it
Mr Marks
you testified that
in the UK case Mr Depp was looking to
clear his name correct
that's my uh assumption yes and yes or
no did Mr Depp clear his name through
that lawsuit
uh I'm uh I wasn't in the UK and I'm uh
not going to uh opine on that that's not
what I've been engaged to talk about you
don't know one way or the other whether
Mr Depp cleared his name through that
lawsuit Jack in your honor ask an answer
I'll sustain the objection next question
you understand can you please put up um
exhibit defendants exhibit 115.
did in looking through the documents did
you see headlines from October 25th 2018
almost two months before the op-ed the
Mr Depp would not be in Pirate six
I yeah I I saw that there was
speculation uh in different Publications
none uh uh
quoting a Disney executive if you will
not none being definitive
and and by the way I I can't see what
where's this article from I just see the
headline
to dailymail.com
so uh the The Daily Mail is a UK
publication
all right let's move I mean do you know
or not
do I know what do you know if it's a UK
publication or not I I
I think that the Daily Mail is but I'm
not sure okay now did you review the
deposition testimony in this case of uh
the Walt Disney corporate designee yes
okay and do you recall that the
corporate designee testified that Disney
produced all documents related to its
business relationship with Mr Depp
including considering the Mr Depp for
any work with Disney or future Pirates
films and she did not recall seeing the
op-ed or any documents referring to the
op-ed in that in that production of
documents
I I read the uh the deposition I I don't
recall seeing the op-ed in what Disney
produced what I do recall uh is the um
uh that the person giving that
deposition for Disney uh really had no
contact with uh uh Jerry Bruckheimer or
Sean Bailey uh he just was some of the
Disney put up who didn't know anything
is what I can you understand you're a
lawyer right you understand that a
corporate designee is supposed to be in
the shoes
of the corporation talking for Disney
correct objection your honor I think
that's outside the scope of his
expertise in this case
overruled
I understand that that's what the uh
corporate design is supposed to be but
when I read this day or not
that was the question in touch with the
president of the company
it gives me pause so Disney itself
represented through this through this
person through this witness that it had
no it did not have the op-ed in any of
its files correct
I don't remember that passage in the um
a deposition uh but I I can't remember
she certainly did not quote the op-ed or
produce the op-ed or talk about the
op-ed
now
but I in Hollywood actions sometimes
speak much louder than words and did you
recall that that same corporate designee
said that pirate six is still possibly
in development
uh until Disney says it's not in
development it's in development okay and
can we put up defendants exhibit 134
and you see this is from November 5th
2020. and where's this with this from uh
some uh
Rogue website where is this from
it insidethemagic.com okay okay and it
says Disney reportedly scraps plans for
depths Pirates of the Caribbean sixth
return and that was on November 5th 2020
correct
uh assuming that this is a correct copy
of this random website uh yeah that's
what it says
they're not quoting uh the head of
production it's not a statement by
Disney but that's what this uh woman uh
Rebecca Barton says well two years after
the op-ed it was still a question as to
whether Mr Depp was going to be in
Pirate six
there was no contract for Mr Depp to be
in Pirate six but he was Pirates and uh
there would always be that question
until Pirates has produced or until
Disney says otherwise and November 2020
was at the same time as all the
publicity surrounding the UK case
correct
uh
I I think the UK judgment came out in
November 2020.
and they and this article came out three
days after the Judgment correct
uh if if the Judgment came out and uh on
the second this is three days later in
uh what's this again
moviemagic.com correct by Rebecca uh you
know uh Barton
could I approach your honor all right
foreign
Now isn't it true that you don't recall
when you first read the op-ed
as I sit here today I don't recall when
I first read it you don't even you don't
I mean it wasn't a big deal to you you
didn't read it in 2018 correct
I have a wife two kids a full-time job I
don't remember okay
and
you have no idea when you first read it
I just want to make sure I understand
that objection asked and answered look I
I wasn't saying the objection next
question okay I sustained the objection
okay next question
now
you as an expert in the entertainment
field do you know any actresses whose
careers have gotten better after making
accusations of a domestic abuse against
an actor in Hollywood
I think uh you know that the the the the
taint sticks uh and uh to both sides uh
and I I can't think of any actresses who
have uh prevailed uh and who've been
canceled
have you thought you know of any
actresses whose careers have gotten
better after making accusations of
domestic abuse against a man in
Hollywood I I haven't been asked to
opine on that but I can I certainly will
look into it I I don't think that this
is something the answer is no right you
don't know
again I I assume uh that uh so yes you
never thought her career would get
better by bringing this out I don't know
all right thank you I have nothing all
right redirect
Mr Marks you were asked a series of
questions about a number of Publications
and publicity related to Mr death
um by Mr nadelhoff do you recall those
questions
he asked a lot of questions about a lot
of articles
and sir based on your experience in the
entertainment industry do you have an
understanding of what types of
Publications carry the most weight in
Hollywood
the Publications to carry the most
weight in Hollywood
in my opinion after all these decades
are variety Hollywood Reporter uh
Washington Post Wall Street Journal New
York Times those are the Publications
Mr navalhoff asked you a number of
questions about certain headlines
related to Mr Depp and various news
coverage related to Mr Depp
do you have an opinion about the impact
of of those articles that you looked at
with Mr nadelhoff on cross-examination
on Mr Depp's reputation in Hollywood
again I don't remember all the Articles
what I do know is that Johnny Depp had
always had articles about him and that
that didn't change the Baseline uh a few
had a big project and it had a role for
Johnny Depp that didn't change the
Baseline
is your opinion about the op-ed misheard
author different than that
my opinion about the op-ed in the
Washington Post is was a different that
was uh uh had a a different quality of
of headline and article
thank you your honor no further
questions is this witness subject to
recall uh he is your honor all right sir
since you're subject to recall the rule
of witness does apply for you so you
cannot discuss your testimony and do not
uh watch any of the case okay sir but
you're free to go today sir okay thank
you thank you all right watch your step
there
all right your next Witness
plaintiff calls Douglas banyo your honor
okay can you spell that last name for me
b a n i a thank you
the your honor may approach for just a
moment okay sure
foreign
testified truthfully in this case for
penalty of law yeah
good afternoon sir
yes ma'am good afternoon Mr Banya
uh will you please State your full name
for the record yes Douglas bamia
and Mr Banya what do you do for work
I am an intellectual property that
damages and valuation expert
do you have any particular specialty in
your line of work uh yes my specialty is
uh using internet and social media
analysis when I'm quantifying value or
I'm calculating damages or if I'm
analyzing the impact of social media or
Internet events
where do you work I work at nevium which
is located in San Diego California
how long have you worked there 10 years
what's your position I'm a founding
principal and an analyst
I'd like to talk a little bit about your
educational background for a moment
where did you attend college
I received my bachelor's degree in
cinema from San Diego State University I
graduated in 1997.
and after you graduated in 1997 did you
pursue another degree yes I went
directly to San Diego State University
got a master's degree in television film
New Media production
was there any particular reason you
chose to go to San Diego State for that
uh the New Media production side of that
program I really liked this was I
graduated from there in 2000 so this is
even before YouTube was found so the
whole idea of putting film on the
internet kind of analyzing the internet
and using analytic tools to see how
things are doing on the Internet is what
that's what's That's What attracted me
and that's what I learned there as well
what did you do after you got your
master's degree
um after the Master's Degree I moved to
Los Angeles and I was an independent
filmmaker for a while then I got
introduced to intellectual property and
I started working for a a small boutique
IP firm back in San Diego what was the
boutique firm you went to
what was the name of the firm yes the
name of the firm was consort
and what what did Contour do consort
values intellectual property for various
business reasons they do litigation
Support Services as well
and when you say intellectual property
what do you mean
um when I talk about intellectual
property I'm mostly talking about
um copyrights patents and trademarks uh
I might include related intangible
assets such as domain names websites
internet accounts but IP for me is
mostly brands
publicity rights copyrights trademarks
what type of work did you do while you
were at Consular
um at various positions there but um I
was a research analyst as a financial
analyst
I was a Director of Business Development
my last position there was a principal
and what kinds of things did you work on
uh we worked on you know valuation our
clients you know they needed evaluation
of their IP portfolio for maybe tax or
estate reasons you know a lot of
litigation support like I'm doing now
somebody infringes on a trademark or
publicity rights uh that was actually
the place I got my I was my first expert
witness job I was a named expert on a
right of publicity case
um
representing the retired players of the
NFL against the NFL they're using their
name and likeness without permission so
services such as that
how long did you work at consort
as that common sore for 10 years
after concert where did you work then at
nevium where I am now
and did you found nevium yes
what kind of work does nevium do
and the fbm does several things that
provides several Services who we value
intellectual property for various
reasons tax estate to m a business
transactions you know we not only
provide the value of a business but we
can break that value what percent of the
value is this trademark portfolio or
this patent portfolio
we do litigation support so like I'm
here I testify in cases you know maybe a
false endorsement case somebody uses a
celebrity's name and likeness without
permission maybe there's a trademark
infringement case you use a brand
without permission
um you know a defamation case such as
this you know what's the impact of
something that was posted online uh
so the Third Kind of bucket of services
we offer
um
is brand monetization strategies so I
think the best way to explain that is is
companies have business plans they have
marketing plans they don't have IP plans
so we come in and work with with
customers with our clients understand
their business and their marketing plans
and help them build an IEP plan that
fits in with those two so they can
essentially make more money off their
branded products and services
um and I think what's important with all
that is you know what differentiates us
with competitors is we use internet and
website analytic tools and all
everything we do you know everything is
online now and um uh understanding those
tools when calculating value or
calculating damages is important
do you have any professional
certifications uh I am a certified
licensing professional that is a
designation given by the licensing
executive Society
Les Les is a not-for-profit organization
that supports professionals like me who
who deal with a lot of Licensing
um but I'm a Google analytics individual
by the Google analytics individual
qualification that is a test given by
Google for those that understand and
pass a test related to
internet Analytics
can you explain a little bit about what
Google analytics is
yeah so Google analytics is a web
service
um
provided by Google and it's used by
business owners and website owners to
understand the traffic that comes to
their websites so essentially once you
sign up for your Google analytics
account you're given a bit of code and
you embed that code into various web
your web pages then you can log in and
you can see like who's coming to my
website what are they doing and really
it's essentially a tool for search
engine optimization you know the goal of
the web is to show up number one in
Google organic so then you you know
you'll tweak your website a bit you'll
look at your analytics see if you're
showing up on on the first page of
Google if not you know you can use those
analytics to keep playing around and try
to end up on the first page of Google
are you a member of any professional
organizations
I'm a member of the international
trademark Association that is a an
organization they're actually having
their annual conference here in DC so I
popping back and forth to that
um I I'm on their right of publicity
panel I just gave a presentation on
Monday
uh I'm a non-attorney member of uh the
American Bar Association I'm on their
copyright and social media committee
um your honor at this point plaintiff
would um offer Mr Banya as an expert in
Internet and social media analytics all
right objection
all right so move thank you
Mr Banya what were you asked to do in
this case
I was asked to analyze the impact of the
uh this uh the allegations of domestic
abuse abuse made by Miss heard as it
relates to our 2016 restraining order
and then asked to also analyze the
republication of that alleged abuse in
her 2018 Washington Post op-ed
what work have you done in connection
with forming your opinions relative to
that
so I identified the best tools to use in
this case which are Q scores
Google Trends and a historic Google
search results
you used a few terms in there I just
want to break them down a little bit
what's a q score
uh accuse score is there's a there's a q
Score company that's been around for
about 50 years and what they do is they
measure how well a brand or a celebrity
or Sports character is known and how
much they're liked and they also measure
how much they're disliked
who else besides you uses Q scores
Q scores are used by you know any
company that you know organizations that
license in a celebrity or a brand to
endorse their product or service
um the PGA golf tour is actually using Q
scores right now they're using Q scores
in Google search results they have a
pool of 40 million dollars that they're
going out to their players so depending
on their Google search results and their
Q scores and other metrics I'm sure
they're using those uh to you know
divide up that pool of money
and I think you also mentioned Google
Trends what's that yeah Google Trends is
another service offered by Google
you know if we know everything starts
with a Google search these days there's
you know five billion daily searches on
Google and Google Trends allows a user
like me or you to go into Google Trends
and analyze a search traffic for various
key terms anything you really want maybe
there's a new football player and you
want to see how that football player is
trending compared to the team over time
or maybe something related to you know
Ukraine or maybe a celebrity so Google
Trends just shows you what kind of
search volume is happening during
various points of time
what are historical Google search
results
so historical Google search results are
search using Google there's actually an
area where you can go back in time and
see what was showing up in Google during
that time uh and it's it's really the
best indication of what websites would
have appeared back in time
oftentimes you know working with my
monetization clients we want to know hey
how were you ranking years ago for your
branded service or your branded company
it will go back in time and look and
then in litigation you know we're always
going back in time you know so we want
to figure out what was most likely
happening what websites were served back
then and when you know what websites
were served back then you typically know
what people were reading and thinking
about
why did you choose these particular
tools for your analysis in this case
um
well the Q scores I really thought it
was the best idea to understand Mr
Depp's Q score is right before 2016
before the abuse allegations just to see
where he is at then I wanted to see his
Q scores right after the 2016 alleged
abuse allegations and then I wanted to
see his Q scores after the 2018
Washington Post op-ed just to see if
there was any changes during that period
of time
and what about your decision to use
Google Trends and historical Google
search results yeah I mean I felt that
like those two tools together were
perfect because what I wanted to do
is understand
you know as I mentioned everyone's going
to Google to figure things out you know
what what were people who when people
Google Johnny Depp prior to these
alleged abuse allegations what websites
were coming up and what was the public
consuming about him then I wanted to
know that after and then after the the
op-ed so I used Google Trends just to
identify the dates in time in which then
I went into the historic Google search
results I searched for Mr debb and then
I changed those dates to go back in time
and then
um I analyzed the top three websites of
each search
based on the analysis you did in this
case have you formed any opinions
yeah my analysis shows that prior to
prior to 2016 and the allegations
um the abuse allegations Mr Depp was not
portrayed in a negative connotation
um
you know that's the first thing that I
that I that I identified did you form
any other conclusions
um I
I realized that those websites were
coming up were mostly about his career
his characters Johnny Depp as the
individual you know his interests then
after the
2016 Mark uh you know the majority of
those results turned into negative
things about the abuse allegations and
then even more so after the op-ed there
seemed to be kind of a theme or a flavor
of not only the abuse allegations but
his drinking and and drug use
did that answer your question yes okay
yeah
um Mr Bunny have you prepared a
demonstrative um that depicts how you
use Google Trends in this case yes
um your honor at this time uh we'd like
permission to approach I have heard copy
thank you
foreign
demonstrative a
and just for the record we've marked
these as plaintiffs 1236 for
identification 1236 for identification
do you want to publish to the jury yes
please okay
foreign
can you explain for the jury what is
depicted in this demonstrative that you
prepared yes so this is
um this is the Google Trends data
uh you're gonna see that it runs from
2004 uh into 2020.
and you're going to notice the different
spikes
those spikes represent
uh when people were searching for Mr
Depp
you can also notice here I've got the
red line uh just showing the dates uh
when misheard filed the restraining
order oh can I
can I write on this you can touch the
screen yes okay yes sir thank you for
your honor yeah so here I'm talking
about in this line here is it's just the
date and time in which misheard alleged
the abuse and filed the restraining
order and then this line here is the
December 18 2018 op-ed and what I wanted
to do
is identify the peaks of interest in Mr
Depp and you're going to notice here I
found 17 spikes of interest that I
analyzed and then the 51 key web pages
we're going to get into later I I've
analyzed the top three search results
for each Spike and then here I I analyze
the seven spikes after uh you know the
2016
allegations of abuse and then again
after the December 18 2018 op-ed
um once you determined these spikes the
periods of significant interest in
searches for Johnny Depp um on Google
what did you do with that information
so
again the purpose of using Google Trends
was just to understand when there's the
most interest in Johnny Depp because for
some reason something was going on in
the news in the media people are turning
to Google to search for Mr Depp so then
I I went to my web browser uh and and
then I I searched for Johnny Depp in
Google but before I did so I have a
separate web browser I call my workbench
browser you know I don't log into
anything it's important to be logged out
of Google because Google keeps a profile
on you and your search results could be
biased based on that profile then also
when you go into a web browser you have
to clear your cache you have to clear
your history clear all your data and
make sure you can get the most unbiased
search results as possible so I went
into Google uh
I typed in Johnny Depp and then I
searched and set the time periods for
the various points here that you see
labeled with letters
do you have a demonstrative that shows
an example of one of those points that
you um you examined yes okay Tom could
we go to um the second Banya
demonstrative please
yeah so this is this is an uh an example
of I believe it was Spike or Point O in
the Google Trends so what I did is I
went into Google I cleared everything as
I as I told you made sure I was logged
out of Google and here you can see I
typed in Johnny Depp I hit the search
and then what I did is went to this tool
area which pulls a drop down area for
the date and I set the date to match the
Google Trend Spike of November of 2004
then we had these top three websites
that came up I I downloaded those
websites and then I analyzed them
so did you do undertake this analysis
for each of the 17 points on the on the
prior slide that we looked at yes
correct and what did you do once you had
your web page results uh such as on this
demonstrative
do you mean when I reviewed each web
page yes yes so what I was looking for
is in a were these web pages or articles
did they have anything to do with the
alleged abuse did they have anything to
do with his alcohol drug use did they
have anything to do with his worth
ethics so I basically
you know try to understand you know the
the content and and of each website or
article
did you look at all of the results that
turned up when you were in these
historical searches
I I only
um uh reviewed the top three why did you
choose the top three uh so I reviewed
the top three because the research shows
that about 50 to 75 percent of the
people only click on the top three so I
wanted to get the majority of the
searches
Tom I think we can take that down for
now thank you
what did you determine about the results
that you found for the period prior to
Ms heard's first allegations of abuse
so I determined that you know Mr Depp
was not portrayed in any negative
connotation the web results were about
his life and his career as acting his
you know pictures of him you know
relationships he was in you know just
pretty normal stuff
and what did you determine about the top
results after misheard's initial
allegations in 2016 and then the
republication in the op-ed in 2018.
okay
foreign
what did you find about the results
um of the top web pages that you
determined after misheard's initial
allegations and then again after the
publication of the op-ed yeah so after
the initial allegations in 2016 I found
that the majority of them had to do with
the the lead shippings
and then after I realized that the the
ones the web pages that we're dealing
with the alleged abuse then started
talking about is is drinking and Drug uh
drinking and doing drugs so it appeared
to me that um you know they became
negative after 2016 but then after 2018
they even included you know the the
alleged abuse but also included this the
drunk drinking and drug use
did you form any opinions about the
results that didn't refer to the
allegations of abuse
that didn't
I formed an opinion that
um
I'm not following your question I'm
sorry that's right we can move on
um did any of the results that you
analyzed refer to Mr Depp's work ethic
no
did you form any overall opinions about
the results in the web pages that you
looked at following Ms herd's
accusations of abuse
yes uh as I stated
um
you know prior to 2016 the web pages
were just about his daily life and
career after the 2016 marker point they
tended to include the majority of them
included uh you know the allegations of
abuse and then after the 2018 op-ed uh
the ones that included the allegations
of abuse were also talking about
drinking and drug use what was your
overall view of the connotation of those
results then yeah so Mr Depp was
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the
2016 allegations of abuse and even more
so after the 2018.
you mentioned you also looked at Q
scores as part of your analysis how are
Q scores calculated yes so Q scores
um it's a it's a survey of 1800 people
that happens twice a year uh and
um
what they do is uh it's internet based
and they they measure how well with
celebrity or a brand is known how how
much they're liked and how much they're
disliked few scores you know include
sports figures celebrities even cartoon
characters brands
so that's how the scoring system works
do you have a demonstrative that
reflects the Q score analysis that you
prepared yes
okay Tom could we have um demonstrative
C please
and Mr Banya what does this tell us
about the the Q score analysis that you
completed
yeah so what this is saying again you
know these spikes are the Google Trends
that you've already seen but what I've
overlaid are his Q scores shown in the
red green and purple area
and and as you recall I wanted to find
out his Q score prior to the allegations
of abuse in 2016 where he had a positive
Q score of 11 and a negative Q score I'm
sorry a positive Q score of 35 and a
negative Q score of 11 and then I looked
at the Q scores after and then after the
op-ed
and what did you determine about those Q
scores
yeah so what you can see here is
positive Q score which is represented in
red was a 35 and that was prior to the
alleged abuse in the restraining order
then after that
um his Q score a positive Q score
dropped to a 31. and what that's saying
is less people liked him after
um
after the the date of the 2016 alleged
abuse and then his negative Q score went
up from an 11 to a 16 which is telling
you that more people disliked him during
that time frame
and what did you find about the final Q
scores that you looked at for Mr duck
yeah then you can see the Q score C that
I have there in purple uh his positive Q
score uh went from a 31 to a 29 his
negative Q score went from a 16 to a 15.
so now it was positive Q score dropped
again from a 31 to a 29 meaning less
people had a positive impression of Mr
death and then his negative Q score did
go from a 16 to a 15 so not as many
people disliked Johnny during that time
frame
what are your overall opinions about The
Q scores that you analyzed
so my overall opinions are you know as I
mentioned earlier I wanted to analyze
the Q scores during this snapshot of
time I wanted to understand what they
were before during and after the op-ed
and what this tells me is his positive Q
score went from a 35 to a 29 and then
his negative went from an 11 to a 15. so
what the Q scores is telling me is the
public perception of Mr Depp has been
damaged you know they they like him less
and they dislike him more
based on all of the analyzes that you
completed in this case what are your
final opinions about Mr Depp's
reputation over this period of time
yeah so my opinions are that you know Mr
Depp was not portrayed in a negative
connotation prior to the 2016
allegations of abuse
and then Mr Depp's image he was
portrayed in a negative connotation
after the 2016 allegations of abuse and
then more so after the 2018 Washington
Post op-ed uh and then the Q scores
represent that uh you know the public
thinks he's damaged they think uh less
likely of him his positive excuse Q
score has gone down and they don't like
him even more because it's negative Q
score went from the 11 to the 15.
I have no further questions of this
witness your honor all right ladies and
Gentlemen let's go ahead and take our
afternoon recess of 15 minutes do not
discuss the case and do not do any
outside research just stay right there
for a second sir
okay
foreign
did not discuss your case even with the
attorneys at this point or your
testimony okay sir okay all right you
can step down we'll be back in about 15
minutes okay
at 3 35. all right let's work okay thank
you
is
good
this means you're only down one right
that's right okay perfect this is 16 39.
thank you all right
go ahead and get the jury
all right
foreign
all right please be seated all right
cross-examination
good afternoon Mr Banya good afternoon
Mr Banyan you understand that this case
is about the op-ed in December of 2018
correct
I understand this case to be about the
allegations of domestic abuse both
um
as it relates to the 2016 and the
republication of that in the 2018
Washington Post op-ed you understand
that Mr Depp is only suing Amber about
the op-ed from December 2018 correct
my understanding is I can base my
understanding on my analysis which
includes the 2016 allegations that's
your analysis but do you understand what
Mr Depp is suing Amber for in this case
section your honor to the extent it
calls for a legal conclusion
I'd also say sustain the objection next
question did you read the complaint in
this case yes did you understand that Mr
Depp was only suing for the op-ed about
the op-ed yes okay
and it's he was not Mr Depp was not
suing Amber in this case from his
complaint about the accusation she made
in 2016 correct
that is my understanding right and
you're not able to separate out how Mr
Depp's reputation was impacted from the
op-ed in 2018 versus how it was impacted
when misheard filed for divorce in 2016.
correct
that is not correct
okay
yes sir
thank you
Mr van you took a deposition in this
case yes I did and I was asking you the
questions in that case is that right
that's correct okay
and
you took that deposition on March 21st
2022
that's correct okay and you were under
oath at the time correct
yes okay and you're under Earth to tell
the truth correct correct
can you turn to page 83 of your
transcript
which is on the 21st page of the
I'm here okay and you see line nine
yes and I ask you are you able to
separate out how Mr Depp's reputation
was impacted from the op-ed versus how
it was impacted by one misheard filed
for divorce and your answer was no
correct
correct okay
and you're not able to separate out how
Mr Depp's reputation was impacted from
the op-ed in 2018 versus the publicity
surrounding when Mr Depp sued the Sun
newspaper in the United Kingdom when a
sun writer called Mr deck a wife beater
correct
are you still reading from a deposition
no I'm asking your question now please
repeat that you're not able to separate
out how Mr Depp's reputation was
impacted from the op-ed in 2018 versus
the publicity surrounding when Mr Depp
sued the Sun newspaper in the United
Kingdom when a sun writer called Mr Depp
a wife beater objection compound your
honor
sustained you're not able to separate
out how Mr Depp's reputation was
impacted from the op-ed in 2018 versus
the publicity surrounding when Mr Depp
sued the Sun newspaper in the United
Kingdom correct my analysis shows that
the
um
the web documents that I reviewed after
the 2018 allegations respectfully this
is a yes or no question this is a yes or
no question
please repeat the question you're not
able to separate out how Mr Depp's
reputation was impacted from the op-ed
in 2018 versus the publicity surrounding
when Mr Depp sued the Sun newspaper in
the United Kingdom that was not part of
my analysis to carve that out
and you didn't you wouldn't you were not
able to separate it correct I didn't try
to okay and so you don't you couldn't
I didn't try it okay
and you understand
that the article Mr Depp sue the sun
over had the headline that said how can
J K Rowling be genuinely happy casting
wife beater Johnny Depp in the new
Fantastic Beasts film correct
uh I don't recall if that's one of the
articles I reviewed
did you unders do you know if that
article came out before Miss Herz OP ED
I don't know
now
you're not offering an opinion as to how
the op-ed for misheard in December 2018
impacted Mr Depp's career correct
I'll repeat that please you're not
offering an opinion as to how the op-ed
from misheard in December 2018
impacted Mr Depp's career correct okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in December
2018 impacted Mr Depp's reputation
what I'm doing is it's a yes or no are
you doing are you offering opinion to
that or not
my opinion is related to his Public
Image you're not offering an opinion as
to how the op-ed for misheard in
December 2018 impacted Mr Depp's
reputation correct
I'm not talking
exactly about his reputation correct
and you're not offering an opinion as to
how the op-ed for misheard in December
2018 impacted Mr Depp's Public Image
correct
I mean I'm offering an opinion that
after the 2018 yes or no other image
it's a yes or no you're not offering an
opinion as to how the op-ed for misheard
in December 2018 impacted Mr Depp's
Public Image
I am turn to your deposition transcript
please
and if you go to page 74 which is on
page 19
.
and you see line area there yes you see
line one
starting on line one I asked you and
you're not going to testify how the
December 2018 op-ed impacted Mr Depp's
Public Image answer that's correct
that that was your testimony at the time
okay well well
perception
at the time correct okay yes and that
was your answer on March 21st 2022
correct
the yes the date of the deposition so
that was a month and a half ago correct
okay
and you're not offering an opinion as to
whether the op-ed for misheard made Mr
debt more hireable or less hirable
correct correct okay
as to the articles that came up in the
Google searches that you spoke about it
was you made the determination whether
the Articles had a quote negative
connotation or not right
correct okay
and so that's just your view if an
article had a negative connotation about
Mr Depp right
yes that's my opinion that they had a
negative connotation right so if an
article criticizes Mr def's acting for
example you're not considering that
article as having a negative connotation
about Mr Depp correct
repeat that please so if an article
criticizes Mr Depp's acting you're not
considering that article as having a
negative connotation about Mr dapp
correct correct okay
now in your analysis of Google spikes
the highest spike in searches for Mr
Depp was in January
2004 correct correct okay and can
I guess you guys have it can you put up
the demonstrative 1236
yeah it's published
and can you see that Mr can we can we
make it just a little bit bigger
okay so the if I'm understanding you
correctly
a is where the most searches were
conducted about for Johnny Depp correct
correct and that's from January 2004
correct correct so that was 18 years ago
correct okay and that was when Miss
heard was 18 years old but I don't know
okay the top Spike you mark as a hundred
correct I did not Mark that but Google
Trends uh identified that spica's 100.
and where it says 100
you don't know how many people actually
searched for Johnny Depp at that point
correct
well the Google Trends algorithm marks
the highest point of search as a hundred
and then everything is compared to that
as a ratio or a percent so if you notice
that a is a hundred everything else is
lower than that because everything is
being compared to that highest point
right so you don't know how many people
actually did the search for Johnny Depp
in January 2004 correct correct it could
be a hundred or it could be a million
right
I don't know and you don't know if it's
actually human beings doing these
searches correct
as opposed to as opposed to bots or
something like that
I did not do an analysis to determine if
it was a bot or a human being but Google
Trends is a tool that's going to show
you during a time frame the highest
point of search interest as a hundred
okay
but you don't know if it you don't know
if it's humans Bots my cat doing the
searches correct objection asked and
answered sustained next question
yeah
now
in all of these Google spikes
Miss heard's op-ed never came up as one
of the top three searches in any of the
Google spikes correct
well that is correct because Google
Trends is based on a search of a word or
a name and because Mr Depp's name was
not mentioned in that op-ed Google
Trends did not pick that up so a person
does a search for Johnny Depp
and the op-ed doesn't come up correct
in my analysis the op-ed did not come up
okay
okay and in fact
the red line the red dotted line all the
way to the right that shows
when the op-ed was published on December
18 2018 correct yes okay and the
searches are actually going down right
after the red line correct
as opposed to the searches in 2004.
look at the red line look at the red
dotted line and you have two you have
two points here right there
those go down from the time of the op-ed
correct
correct okay and isn't it true that the
next
I guess Spike happens
in March of 2019 correct
right there yes
and do you know that it was March of
2019 when Mr Depp sued Amber Heard in
this case
no I didn't look at that date right you
didn't look at any articles
for the for that for this bullet correct
that's correct okay
and
since Miss heard's op-ed came out on
December 18 2018 you would agree with me
that by definition all the spikes you
analyzed before December 18 2018 could
not have been caused by the op-ed right
correct
so articles about Mr Depp's drug use
before December 2018 could not have been
caused by the op-ed correct
correct okay and you in this chart
analyze only two spikes after the op-ed
isn't that right
that is correct okay
and the first Spike you analyzed after
December 2018
V is V correct yes
and is that from
is that January 2020
roughly yes okay so that's January 2020
is over a year after the op-ed by Miss
hurt correct that's correct okay
and then the next Spike you analyze was
T correct yes
and that was in approximately July 2020.
correct okay so that was a year and a
half after Miss herd's op-ed correct
yes okay
and again none of the Articles and then
you and then for V and T if I understand
it
you then analyze the top three
searches that come that came up or the
top three websites that came up after a
search
correct okay
and none of the Articles you analyze in
those Google spikes after the op-ed were
the op-ed correct correct okay
and isn't it true that the headlines of
the Articles over a year after the op-ed
that you analyzed were about Mr Depp
suing the sun in the UK
for a sunwriter calling Mr Depp a wife
beater
you would have to pull those articles
back up I don't have those in front of
me
isn't it true that the article and and
just so I understand it V and T that
would mean there were six articles
correct that you analyzed yes okay and
isn't it true that the article on
February 26 2020 the headline was quote
Johnny Depp's disturbing alleged text
messages read aloud in court as libel
lawsuit begins
again I don't have that article in front
of me I did produce those as part of my
analysis I don't have that in front of
me if you'd like to show it to me and
you understand that that was about the
lawsuit against the sun in the UK not
about the op-ed correct
again I did not have that in front of me
and the other another article that came
up on February 27 2020 is one of the top
three hits when you search for Johnny
Depp what the headline was quote let's
burn Amber text allegedly sent by Johnny
Depp about X read in court
I mean if you want to talk about these
articles we need to bring them up this
is your opinion you don't you don't
recall what articles you analyzed I mean
there's a lot of Articles here I don't I
didn't memorize each title there was
there were six articles that you
legalized in the
almost two years after the op-ed all
right would you can you bring those up
and we can talk about them and on July
19 2020 the headline was quote Hollywood
nervously awaits Fallout from explosive
Johnny Depp trial
you don't you don't recall one way or
the other whether that was one of the
articles in either V or t
again I know if you want to bring up my
documents I know document
9j
909 K and 9M are mentioning the op-ed
again I don't have those and when you
say and when you say mentioning the
op-ed does that mean that it just
references that Mr Depp sued Amber Heard
in Fairfax no it talks about how he's
alleged to have abused her that relates
to the op-ed doesn't it say I mean
another headline from July 19th 2020 the
headline was quote Hollywood nervously
awaits Fallout from exclusive Johnny
Depp trial objection asked and answered
sustain the objection next question you
understood that was about the lawsuit
against the sun in the UK correct
objection let me ask about that
overruled again I would like to talk
about these articles but I need to see
them
and on July 19 2020 the headline was
quote Johnny Depp versus Amber Heard all
The Nasty bits of the UK trial and it's
all nasty
that was in point T correct
again I do not have that list in front
of me if you'd like to bring that up we
could talk about it and you understood
that was about the lawsuit against the
sun in the UK correct I do not
and on July 19 2020 the headline was
quote Johnny Depp claims in the sun he
beat ex-wife complete lies Court told
that was the quote correct I don't see
that here
that was in your report correct
I I would have to look at the documents
again I would be happy to discuss them
if you would bring those up and then you
previously had a chart that had articles
from November 2020 correct
I'm sorry say that you previously had a
chart that included articles from
November 2020 correct objection around
or maybe we approach it okay sure
you understood it was Mr Depp's decision
to sue the sun correct
I I don't know that's not part of my
analysis now
you talked about Q scores and your test
in your direct testimony correct correct
and you testified about three particular
Q scores for Mr Depp right
three periods of time is the Q scores
that I analyzed and you're not offering
an opinion as to why Mr def's Q score
has changed correct that's correct
and Q scores can go up and down for
actors for any sort of reason correct
that's possible
you recall testifying that they could go
up and down for any sort of reason in
your deposition
yeah they can go up and down for many
different reasons so you're not offering
an opinion that Mr Depp's Q scores were
damaged because of Miss herd's op-ed
correct that's correct okay
and in comparing the Q scores from
before the op-ed to the Q scores after
the op-ed Mr Depp's Q scores dropped by
two points correct
I I don't have those Q scores in front
of me but if if you're looking at them I
believe we can show we can show the
third page of this demonstrative
what was your question please his Mr
Depp's positive Q scores from B to C
dropped by two points correct yes
you're not an expert on statistics
correct correct and even though you're
not an expert you have an idea about
what the term statistically significant
means correct yes
and statistical significance is a
measure of whether your findings are
meaningful right
yes I don't think you need statistics to
understand Q scores and you don't know
if there's any significance to a drop in
two points in positive Q score correct
so there absolutely is when you're
ordering Q scores
points of time you go to your deposition
page 113.
which is on 29.
okay
at 10 Atlanta page 113 line 10 it says
so you're not offering an opinion as to
the significance of a change in Q score
correct answer correct well you're
talking about statistically a a
difference what I'm talking about is how
we use Q scores in the industry when you
see a q score from dropping from a 31 to
a 29 there's an issue is this somebody
you really want to hire to endorse your
products or your service no you probably
not you want to look into why why what
is going on in the public to to make
these Q scores drop like that and you
don't know exactly the significance
between five or six points of drop and
queue score correct correct okay
foreign
now
and it shows here that Mr Depp's
negative Q score actually got better
from point B to point C correct correct
so that's actually better for Mr Depp
correct correct okay and you understood
you understand that Dr Alan Jacobs
reviewed your opinions in this case yes
and you understand that Dr Jacobs
reviewed additional Q score data correct
yes okay can we please put up
plaintiff's exhibit 889
at 117.
Mr Banya do you understand this as a
chart of Mr Depp's Q scores
from Winter 2012 through summer of 2021
yes
do you have any reason to question the Q
scores
that are that are just that are shown in
this chart
uh like I said my deposition I have not
received actual data to build this chart
but I don't have any reason to to not
believe that this is accurate as I
understand it Q scores are performed on
a celebrity like Mr Depp twice a year
correct
yes so there's winter of a particular
year and then there's
summer of a particular Year yes and the
winter scores come out around February
is that right but I don't have that
information in front of me but it sounds
right and so would you know when the
summer scores come out uh I don't okay
and this chart shows
well permission to publish this chart is
a demonstrative of your honor any
objection
I don't think this witness has laid an
appropriate foundation for you he said
he has no reason to question the Q
scores out loud as a democrine
um
and so this chart shows Mr Depp's
positive and negative Q scores correct
correct and the positive Q scores are in
blue
that's correct
can you blow it up a little bit Michelle
and
and the negative Q scores are in red
yes okay objection your honor may we
approach
Mr Banya the positive Q score for Mr
Depp in the winter of 2012
is 42 correct
it's in between yeah it's in between 40
and 45. okay
and if we if
did you check this actual Q scores that
um
Mr Jacobs
demonstrated in his report
no my analysis was a snapshot of time I
wanted to know Johnny Depp's key scores
directly before the 2012 allegations the
2016 allegations of abuse and after okay
and you see here that the positive Q
scores for Mr Depp dropped from 42 in
the winter of 2012.
to
35
in the summer of 2016 correct
yes that's a seven point drop correct
yes and that's before Miss heard had
heard the divorce filing correct that's
correct
and that drop in Mr Depp's positive Q
scores could have nothing to do
with Miss heard's op-ed correct
correct and that drop could have nothing
to do with the allegations misheard made
after the divorce filing correct correct
and
would you agree
that
the
positive
Q scores
actually start to show an increase for
Mr Depp
after the op-ed
there's a decrease and then there's an
increase yep
and the same for the negative
debt Q scores
there's a bit of a positive
and then it goes down correct yes
so really the op-ed had no effect on Mr
Depp's Q scores correct
as I mentioned my analysis looked at the
snapshot of time and it shows that he
was harmed you know from before the
allegations of abuse in 16 to after the
op-ed in 2018. you looked at three Q
scores
and you could have looked at one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen
sixteen Seventeen eighteen I won't even
count the 2021 scores 18 Q scores
correct yep okay and you looked at three
right that's correct and and that's what
you're basing your opinion on that the
op-ed damaged Mr Depp's Q scores yeah so
we need that that's right my question is
a yes or no your Council can come back
sorry if you could just answer his
question no question that's five
I didn't hear your question I
you looked at three Q scores instead of
18 Q scores correct that's correct okay
and did you look at the Q scores at all
after the Dan Wooten article that came
out in April of
of uh 2018.
objection asked an answer General
I don't think I asked that overruled out
loud
no
thank you I have nothing there all right
redirect
Mr Banya on cross-examination you were
asked some questions about uh the fact
that you made a determination about
which of these articles had a negative
connotation do you recall that yes
is that something that you do in uh
situations other than in your analysis
in this case
yeah yeah it's so in non-litigation when
we're building brand monetization
strategies especially if you're going to
work with a celebrity celebrity or an
athlete you want to look at what's going
on out there you know about that
personality you know because celebrities
and athletes you know Q scores can go up
and down you want to analyze the the
time and see what's going on out in the
media do I really want my client to
license in a celebrity that there's
problems out there or an athlete so yes
it's important to look at this
and I believe you were asked um whether
you're offering an opinion in this case
about the impact of the op-ed on Mr
Depp's Public Image do you recall that
yes and I believe you testified that you
are offering an opinion on that is that
right yes what's that opinion well the
opinion is that uh he's portrayed in a
negative connotation after that date
and with respect to the Q scores that
you analyzed um Mr nadelhoff was asking
you about the three points in time that
you looked at why in your opinion was it
appropriate to look at just those three
Q scores
yeah as I was trying to explain you know
Q scores do go up and down we're
analyzing a period of time we want to
see what's happening right before an
event during that event and if there's
another event after that event and that
is our area of analysis
so that's why just these three sets of Q
scores are the appropriate way to
Analyze This
thank you I have nothing further all
right is this witness subject to recall
uh he is your honor all right sir do not
discuss your testimony with anybody
since you are subject to recall but
since you are an expert you are allowed
to stay in the courtroom if you wish
okay okay all right thank you sir all
right you can step down okay
all right your next Witness
you're on a I believe we're calling
Aaron fellati by deposition oh okay
could you put I'm sorry could you put
your microphone we approached there's
two exhibits that we have okay all right
while we're
all right your next witness then thank
your honor uh plaintiff calls Aaron
falotti also known as Aaron Boren
filotti and
um Miss Hertz Council Begins the
questioning thank you
provide your full name
[Music]
and it is Borum your maiden name right
okay so Borum was your name your last
name in the 2014 to 2016 time frame
correct that's correct
Have you communicated with anybody else
from Mr Depp's uh Council other than
Miss Vasquez
uh not that I recall oh excuse me excuse
me I do
um
I don't remember his name I'm so sorry
I feel like I spoke at the time I I
don't know his last name
did you speak to or communicate with
Adam Waldman
perhaps I don't recall his last name
and you recall when that occurred
that
would have been
2019
because I had I had a newborn at that
time
so
maybe May June July something like that
2019.
so this is a tax exchange between you
and Mr Waldman
it appears so
and do you recall speaking to Mr Waldman
at all
yes
and you recall that when you were uh
communicating with Mr Waldman Mr Waldman
was Mr def's attorney
yes
miss vladiator a trained nurse is that
correct
that's correct
do you have any specialties
well I haven't been working
you know like I used to but previously
uh I was trained in addictions
and mental health
and when you say addictions Are there
specific type of addictions you were
trained in
oh but I primarily worked with chemical
dependency
and where did you receive training for
um
addiction and mental health
different
employment places and then I became a
certified registered addiction source
foreign
did you did you work for Dr Kipper
hey not directly but he would hire the
agency I provided nursing services for
which was
turning point I believe
so I worked under his guidance but not
specifically for him
for most of the time there have been
times where I've worked specifically for
him
okay when did you start working for uh
Turning Point Nursing services or
whatever the name of that company was
I
think this would be
somewhere between
2007 square feet
and when did you start to begin to do
any work for Dr Kipper
I believe 2014.
what were the circumstances that started
you working for Dr Kipper in 2014.
I recall correctly it would be for
services for Ms heard
were you ever responsible for Mr def's
nursing care while he was under the
treatment of Dr Kipper
I provided him
two minutes too
so miss Pilates I'm showing you what's
been marked as exhibit two to your
deposition
and
these are
you these are ah tpd
16 929
through
16 959 and as as that the paper
documents you have a set of the paper
documents you have in front of you
the first page
and the first page you might have said
at the bottom also uh
k182
yes I have that okay
do you recognize these as your what what
are these
these are my
nursing notes
except for Miss heard
yes
and these are notes you created
yes
could you create these notes in the
ordinary course of business
yes
um
were you trained and how to prepare
these notes
yes would you write these when
how long after you the visit would you
write up these notes
would depend sometimes I would keep
notes on my phone that I would transfer
to the word document when I when I was
in front of my laptop
and if not possible I would do it
as soon as feasible
and how often would you show these notes
to Dr Kipper
I don't recall at interval
um so if you look at the first page of
the notes
um the first the first entry is August
27 2014 correct
yes
yes
and
you wrote RN has been hired to provide
private nursing care for client Amber
Heard
right right
and RN refers
to you correct
uh and an RN means registered nurse
correct
correct
um
and throughout the notes and you say
this here Amber Heard would be referred
to as client or ah correct
and and Johnny Depp would be referred to
as JD
right
would you agree that Mr Beth and Amber
would get into verbal arguments they
recall a general sense of Discord in the
relationship
what do you mean by General sense of
Discord
reconciliation and and kind of that
repeating pattern
and would you be at times taking care of
Amber because of this the disagreements
between Mr Depp and Amber
I provided emotional support I was not
present with her often but it was
available
over the phone via text and sometimes in
person
do you recall uh that in March 2015 uh
amber went to Australia to be with Mr
debt
yes I remember she went to Australia as
to the dates I would have to look
through documentation to ascertain the
exact dates okay
and on the exhibit two
this is your note of March 7th 2015.
that's correct
and you wrote a client notifies RM via
text of increasing anxiety
if they wrote that
and then on 3 8 15 you wrote RN received
report from Debbie
RN wbw Lloyd correct
correct
do you recall what the report you
received was
on March 8th 2015 from Debbie
I mean I'm just reading my notes sure
so to answer your question no I don't
recall specifics of what the report
would have been
I assume based on this note
that would have been a phone call
okay and it says client will be
returning to Los Angeles on March 9th
2015 accompanied by house manager Ben do
you see that yeah
did you have an understanding as to why
Amber was leaving Australia
in March of 2015.
yes
I don't know if this is the exact timing
but
you know better than I there was an
incident in
Australia
and they had to be misheard and Mr Depp
had to be separated
so Ms heard returned to Los Angeles for
my my nursing notes and I believe Mr
Jack must have stayed in Australia
what was your understanding as to why Mr
Depp and Amber had to be separated
foreign
call
specifics because I wasn't
there or involved at the time but became
involved again I remember
hearing from other people that there was
quite an argument
between the two
do you have any understanding if anyone
was injured
during
um
the argument between the argument
between Amber and Mr Depp physically
injured physically yeah
again I wasn't present so I'm only
speaking
as to what I recall
during that time period And what I sort
of remember hearing from others and also
I just remember
Mr Depp's
finger was injured I can't tell you
specifically which one but I remember
there was an injury to his finger
do you have any understanding as to how
his finger was injured
no
and then
um Aaron you wrote the next note on
March 9th 2015 that says RN and CT and
touch via text and phone calls after
client arrived at 1500
yes I wrote that
and 1500 that you're using military time
correct
correct so that would be 3 P.M
correct and you wrote client expressed
feelings quote sad
right
yes they wrote that do you recall what
Amber was sad about it approximately
March 9th 2015.
I can't
specifically but I would assume based on
my March 8th note
I would make the assumption that those
feelings were in relation to the
relationship issues
you wrote client states she would like
to discuss recent events between her and
husband with RN and private tomorrow
plans are made for RN to visit client at
her home tomorrow
yes I wrote that do you recall
all the conversation you had with Amber
regarding the events between her and Mr
death at this March around this March
9th 2015 time frame
no I don't recall specifics you recall
anything in general
I really don't I'm sorry
admit did did Amber express any um
fear of Mr Depp at this time
don't recall I don't
I don't see that in this note so I I
can't speak to that
um and then the note for uh March 10th
2015. you see that note I do you can
take this down
[Music]
questions
we put up attachment 25 please
this body I'm showing you a text chain
between you and Whitney heard
on March 23 2015. do you see that
and on March uh 23rd 2015 you texted to
Whitney heard Debbie just told me what's
going on and to check with you is Amber
awake or fall asleep do you see that
yeah
and then miss heard wrote she finally
fell asleep you see that
okay then you wrote thank goodness she
must be exhausted
I'm sorry just just to confirm this is
this is from
Whitney heard not
Amber Heard correct
as I understand it it says is that your
understanding
I assume thank you
and then you if you are called over
communicating with Whitney hurts via
text or chat
that sounds familiar okay
and you wrote thank goodness she must be
exhausted you want me to come to the
loft or is she safe and sound asleep
you see that did you see that okay
and then Whitney wrote safe question
mark no she's not
kept saying she wants to kill herself
you see that
see that
were you ever concerned about misheard
safety as it relates to Mr death
so
if she made comments to me that she was
not safe
I would
be concerned
about her to ensure that she was safe
yes
do you recall miss her making comments
to you
about her safety
I remember a general
[Music]
Mr death would have arguments she would
often have her friends around her for
support
but from
a
general
you know physical sense she was she was
always in a safe place
and you mean where you mean in a general
physical sense she was always in a safe
place what do you mean by that
meaning she was always not always I
should say often home often surrounded
with friends she had friends that lived
right down the hallway from her so she
was
always supported
was was Mr Depp friends with uh Marilyn
Manson
yes I believe
Ms fellati I'm showing you
what's marked as exhibit seven and these
are um
texts
that Mr death produced between you and
him
um and I'm focusing on this text message
of October 31st 2015. you see that
well so this text message between you
and Whitney is on March 23rd 2015. you
see that thank you okay and if we go
back to exhibit two
and I'll go back
um
um
there there's no entry for March 23rd
2015. you see that
not everything you did for Miss hurt as
an as a nurse is reflected in these
notes correct
and the next notes we have are November
25th 2015.
do you know why there's
a long um
period where there's no notes
yes perhaps I can shed some light
for you and everyone on the relationship
when I was first hired to care for Ms
heard
I worked full-time you know I was
assigned
24 7 basically
and after a period of time I became more
part-time and on call
uh and I was working with different
clients at the time so I would
how to put it I wouldn't not be working
regularly
but would also be available if an issue
arose or a medication changed needed or
things like that so
I would assume that would account for
this this Gap
why did you move from um
full time to part-time
I don't know the exact answer but I I
assume that's not my decision to make
that's usually the client and or
treating physician
okay so that's the first page of exhibit
two
yes thank you
so if you can
um can you go down to it's about the
Third
paragraph a little bit yes
her report from JD
which refers to Mr Jeff
Debbie RN and Dr Kipper
client ah which is Miss heard
has reportedly been experiencing
increased anxiety and agitation recently
and has had several outbursts of anger
and rage
from what I remember when I was involved
in the case it was to help assist Ms
heard
with some emotional issues anxiety
issues
um in in attempts to assist
in layman's from kind of calming things
down a bit
do you recall any
um examples
that you knew of of anger and rage
showed by Amber
I didn't call her seeing her very angry
have to refer to my notes it was in
London so that would have been 2014.
and I believe it was in reference to a
violating incident where her phone had
been packed and she was quite upset
I saw her angry at that time and other
times I don't recall
were you in London with Amber at the
time
and how was how was Amber showing her
anger
I recalled
Wild
kind of elevated uh voice
yelling crying
uh quite upset
do you recall receiving a call
from Amber
um
around December 16 2015 regarding
this argument between Mr Depp and Amber
specific phone call
do you would you doubt that a phone call
occurred if there's if you wrote it down
in your notes
and now you see the note on
December 17 2015.
yes
and you wrote RN in contact with clients
and notified her that she'd be able to
deliver medications to her home
Aaron waited a door for several minutes
after knocking client greeted our in the
door looking disheveled hair appeared
unbrushed client appeared weepy and sad
Pastor is slouched Klein told Aaron
about argument with husband
aren't over offered emotional support
but reminded client that RM could not
stay as was on duty with another client
and was only visiting in order to
deliver medication
per client she had not been
she had not had contact with husband
since altercation client had visible
bright red blood appearing at Center of
lower lip when RN made client aware that
she acted was actively bleeding on her
lip client stated it was from injury
sustained in the and then it's blank you
see that right there we can keep going
down in the argument between her and her
husband and that it continues to bleed
actively you wrote that
yes
and then you also wrote clients also
states that her head is bruised and that
she lost clumps of hair and altercation
you wrote that
I assume so it's in my notes okay and
then you wrote Aaron briefly with the
client's scalp but was unable to
visualize the hematoma's client had
described
he wrote that
yes I would agree and then you wrote RN
encourage clients to be seen by position
Dr pipper or go to emergency
urgent care for thorough assessment you
see that
they do and then you were a client State
she will contact Dr Kipper tomorrow
client is supported by friends Rocky and
IO who will be staying in clients home
with her who wrote that
I agree yes
okay
and then on December 18 2015 you wrote
client states you went to Dr Kipper's
office and was assessed by NP Monroe t
as Dr Kipper was out of the office you
wrote that
yes an NP stands for nurse practitioner
that's correct
and you understand Monroe T stood from
Monroe tinker
yes
you were called Mr death ever forgot to
take any of his medication
a specific time or ever
in any time where you're working with
him
I would say vaguely yes
Mr Claudia I'm showing it's been marked
as exhibit 11.
to your deposition which is
Pilates 96
through
106. you see that
you recall and you recall receiving this
text message right
a vague memory of this
you recall if you spoke to Amber after
you received this text message
or at any time after you receive this
text message around May 21st May 22nd
2016.
are you saying
or just
I I don't really recall
it could have happened you just don't
recall one way or the other
I would agree with that
and you received this picture from Amber
that's correct
what is this picture of
you can move your
if you want it just heard
and does the picture show redness on
under Miss heard's eyes
you can ask answer as a lay person if
she has such an opinion
if you have an opinion one way or the
other you can let them know
I'm not an expert so I mean there's
color on her face in different areas I
don't know what's what
and you received this first picture
of Amber at 12 36 a.m correct
that's the time
and he received another picture
at 12 36 A.M
it appears so
and who do you see in that picture
also miss Serge
and you received a third picture of
Amber at 12 36 A.M
yes appear so
and is the third picture of amber
yes that's missert
and you received the fourth picture of
Amber at 12 36 A.M
then yes
and and that's worth I think I think
just so it's clear the fourth picture is
of Amber
that's correct and you received that at
12 36 A.M
yes that's the time stamp
and these are pictures of Amber's face
correct
yes that's a picture of her face and
neck
do you recall if you do you recall and
you recall receiving those pictures
like I said I have a vague memory of of
this but I don't
specifically remember this evening yeah
um okay do you know if he reported these
pictures
or
what Miss heard reported to you to Dr
Kipper
contacted Dr Kipper and you know how you
would have contacted Dr Pepper
no I I
did the date time I would sometimes call
email text
you recall if you wrote nurse notes
for this incident
I don't recall
do you want us to look at exhibit two
it's the nursing house yeah
why don't we do that
so there's notes for May 11 2016. you
see that
yeah
and then the next notes for May 26 2016.
yes okay do you know why you didn't
include notes for May 21st 2016.
they don't know
and on May 26th you wrote client texted
RN requesting Ambien as she states She's
suffering from insomnia due to stress
and anxiety client reports quote having
the hardest week of my life
end quote you wrote that
and you were a client states you cannot
deal with the negative media publicity
she has received
surrounding the divorce she requested
from her husband JD
Dr Kipper notified ambient 10 milligrams
qhs PRN 14 order for Dr Kipper client is
encouraged to make appointment with Dr
Kipper in office to be assessed client
did not respond you wrote that
yes
Miss bloody I'm showing you it's been
marked as exhibit 12th year deposition
which is
pilate 114 through 119.
um
you can take a look through them uh it
appears to be notes of your of when you
were Mr Depp's
nurse as opposed to miss herd
feel free to take a look
that's correct I I think these are
Mr or excuse me my nursing notes in
relation to Mr death
so client now is Mr Beck correct
that's correct because these nursing
notes
are in reference to Mr Jeff yes that's
correct okay and in the nursing note for
April 23 2015 you wrote
um
that Dr Kipper will introduce Rosalind
Phillip to Debbie RN and clients Amber H
and Johnny Depp Debbie rml assist in
coordinating session appointments
between clients and Ms Phillips do you
know if Mr Depp and Amber ever saw
Rosalind Phillip
I don't know
and it
had Pilates 117
it shows
notes for June 7th 2016.
correct
you wrote The Following medications were
approved per Dr Kipper to be given to
the client and then there's a list of of
medications uh
you you wrote that you wrote these notes
correct
yes that's correct and did you
understand that Mr Depp was taking those
those medications as of June 7th
2016.
for this nursing note it appears that he
was
taking these medications listed
and then there's a nurse saying notes
for June 26 2016. you see that
um
and it says uh you wrote client is going
through divorce with wife Amber H and is
dealing with the loss of his mother
passed away one month ago
client was provided with the worst
request from wife ah three days after
mother passed away do you see that
yes you wrote that
yes so is it your understanding that
Amber asked for a divorce
this note says that
Mr Depp was provided with divorce
request
from
Ms heard so it appears she she was the
one
requesting it for us right and he wrote
next client states he was not aware ah
won a divorce and expresses confusion
regarding age his desire to terminate
marriage he wrote that
yes is that what Mr Depp told you
I would assume if I wrote it in my net
in
and he wrote uh client's divorce has
been highly publicized and wife ah has
been has been accused him of several
character damaging allegations including
domestic violence
you wrote that correct
correct
was was this uninformed did you write
this based on information Mr Depp
provided you
I don't know I would assume that I've
had discussions with him regarding this
considering that this is a nursing note
for Mr Jeff
did Mr Depp tell you his character had
been damaged as of June 2016.
I don't recall I have to go by what my
note says here so it alludes to that's
something that he had discussed
and you you see where he wrote client
states he felt helpless previously but
is now angry at age and wants to clear
his name Mr Jeff told you that
again I don't recall for sure but I
would go back to my nursing notes
because those were written more at the
time so I would assume that he and I
discussed that
okay farther down
um you wrote RN assisted client in
processing feelings and encouraged
clients to continue utilizing individual
therapy as he responded well to RN's use
of therapeutic communication you see
that
yes and you wrote that correct yes
then your client is resistant stating
quote I don't want anyone like Amber's
wife therapist he has only made things
worse end quote you see that
yes and you wrote that
yes
and words quotes I don't want anyone
like Amber's therapist he's only made
things worse that was something that Mr
Depp told you
again as I have it in quotations I
assume he made that statement
a little farther down you wrote
throughout Aaron's visit client
maintains attention and is actively
participating in conversation client
consume three vodka drinks during RN
sevenf seven hour visit
client did not eat during visit and
drank water only with several prompts
from our end our uneducated client on
possible interactions between prescribed
medication and alcohol
client verbalize understanding but
stated quote right now I need a little
alcohol for all the bad things I'm going
through end quote
that you you wrote those lines
yes
say The Document Speaks best as to how
much how many drinks Mr Depp had
and that Mr duck drank vodka drink three
vodka drinks during your visit
that's what my note says
and then you then you said RN provided
one-on-one emotional support and
encouraged clients limit and are abstain
from alcohol and illicit drugs
you wrote that
yes
um you
you recall why you told Mr Depp to
abstain from illicit drugs
no but I did I did and not just with Mr
deput in my line of nursing provide
education always with any medication
clients are on and contraindications
you know if Mr debba ever took any list
of drugs during during the two during
the 2014 and 2016 time frame
I don't know I didn't I didn't witness
him using any illicit drugs so I can't
speak to that
your honor at this point the questioning
switches over to questions for um by
Council for Mr Dunn
that's all right with us your honor
I'm sorry let's go ahead and break for
the evening we will see you uh in the
morning just do not discuss the case and
do not do any outside research all right
and we'll have the rest of this tomorrow
morning okay thank you
thank you
all right so we'll see everybody at 10
o'clock tomorrow okay thank you thank
you
foreign
foreign
[Music]